那个又两周没有和大家见面了
大家端午节休息的怎么样
我知道大家刚刚过完高考完
然后毕业马上要来
我的期末考试
马上要来
我的接下来就是我的暑假
所以的话呢我觉得同学们最近应该是非常的忙
然后忙到我们最近也是一头转向
今天我才发现我的钟没有对齐
所以我们发现我的时间居然误差了
将近有半分钟左右
下次我们一定把它校正
然后那个即将来了暑假嘛
很多同学们可能有的大学已经毕业了
然后有些同学准备好自己暑假的安排
反正我的104课程呢就会一直陪着大家对吧
我们继续讲我的知识
讲我的那个维护我的小引擎
然后同学们也可以过一个非常充实的暑假
嗯那在那个开始今天的课程之前的话呢
先跟大家就是做一些我的社区里面
同学们的声音的一些反馈
首先的话就是上周我们上上一次课程
应该是上上周
我们决定了我的新引擎的那个名字叫PICO
这个名字还是蛮可爱的
我个人是蛮喜欢这个这个名字的
然后呢我的就是设计师团队呢
就拜托我的设计师团队花了这个一个星期
好好的设计一下新的我的引擎的icon
然后我们基本的想法就是不要变得太多
尽量继承大家已经习惯的东西
所以我们就设计出了我的新的这个icon
那这个新的icon是个什么东西呢
就是我们查了一下PICO
这个单词的意思是意大利语
短笛的意思是一种非常小
但是音域特别广的一种乐器
我觉得这个蛮好的
就很像我的小引擎
就是虽然我们是一个小小引擎
但是我们大家一起努力
其实可以越做越丰富
越做越有趣
所以还蛮契合我的意思的
然后在设计这个图标的时候
它上面设计了很多孔
然后我就问设计师这些孔代表什么
然后我才知道大家的想法是这样
就是说我们上面那个空洞代表的是零
然后呢那个短笛的形状代表的是一
所以一和零又构建了我的计算机世界
哎我就觉得好胖啊
哈哈就是一下子我觉得这个icon好有寓意
所以的话呢在接下来的话呢
我们还有很多工作要做
因为我们要把那个polo的引擎里面的代码的
命名啊
文件名啊
还有我的那个GITHUB上的工程名
可能都要发生一些变化
所以这个事情的话
预计我们还要再持续个一个一个星期左右
然后呢争取能够完成我的小引擎
正式定名为PICO这个引擎的这个这个工程对吧
这也是一件让我们还蛮兴奋的一件事情
另外一个的话呢
就是上周的很多同学已经把作业交上来
我们还是蛮震撼的
就是像这个做的就非常的完备
非常的震撼
怎么样
我觉得任何时候
当我们觉得作业很难的时候
总会有人超额完成
甚至有人觉得这个作业是不是太简单了
这个我从读书时代就明白这个道理
就是你觉得考试不可能有人满分的卷子
总是有人会做满分
然后就是这像这个做的就非常的好吧
所我的动画差值blending
包括我的这个那个controller的
所我的这个stepping
还有那个墙上的sliding全部做出来了
我觉得这个做的还是蛮完备的
其实大家看这个是不是很像一个小游戏的样子
是的
所以我的小引擎代码虽然很小
但是大家基于它做一些你想做的小游戏的话
其实难度并不是很大
而且因为这是知识引擎代码全部开放嘛
所以将来你可以对它做各种变化的
空间也是非常大的
那么其实呢就是我们也在跟同学们交流的时候
发现同学们做这个作业的也没有那么一帆风顺
经常会踩到一些坑
包括我们自己的同学也试做一下
然后呢我们总结了一些比较容易踩坑的地方
比如说我们在做这个动画权重差值的时候
因为有的时候不是只是两个动画差值
有时候可能会三个甚至四个更多的动画在插值
因为这个整个控制的状态比较多嘛
所以大家注意那个动画差值的总权重
一定要归一化
否则的话就会出现一些很奇怪的一些bug
然后呢我们在课程上讲的那个就是动画
blending的时候
一定要用S2
不要用那个简单的一个ENERP的差值
因为你用一个简单的差值的话
就可能会出现一瞬间
就是当COTAN就出现了钝角之间差值的时候
他就会感觉很不自然对吧
但是那一瞬间它就插过去了
所以的话呢这个是我们在做这个系统的时候
同学们一定要小心
然后啊另外一个呢还有一个比较有意思的东西
就是说很多同学说哎无论我怎么做
我这个ASM怎么做
我的这个小人的角色都有点滑步对吧
然后总是觉得自己是不是哪做错了
这一点的话呢
我们跟大家讲
大家千万不要为这个事情这个有太大的压力
因为啊
我们其实这次提供的动画素材量并不够的
因为你真正要做到完美的脚
没有滑步的效果的话
其实要需要大量的素材
比如说人物的斜向移动啊
这些横向移动啊
我们都要提供一些素材
让这个角色看上去更加的真实
而且这样的话我们在插值的时候
这个误差会更小
但是这一次因为是个小引擎
所以我们没有把它做的特别的复杂
所以的话呢在某些情况下
比如说突然走跑跳突然变的时候
不是突然跳起来落地还带带一点前移的时候
比如说你跑着跑着突然跳起来
和和你慢慢走跳起来对吧
和你加上加上一点斜向移动等等
复杂的组合情况下
它确实可能会产生产生一些滑步的情况
所以呢大家的话不要为此而纠结
不要因此而怀疑自己
代码写错了
因为动画系统真的想做到尽善尽美的话
它本身就是非常非常难的
所以的话这些是我的同学们在做上一次
是上一个单元作业的时候
很容易遇到的问题
所以我们104课程的话呢
就是不会每一节课布置作业
但是呢其实每个章节布置作业
它的难度和他的工作量还是有保障的
就是说我觉得
如果同学们把我们就前面几节课的作业
都能做得完的话
实话实说
你基本上会对基础的引擎架构是有所了解的
那接下来的话呢进入我们今天的课程的正文了
今天的课程正文讲什么呢
我们就讲特效系统对吧
就特殊的效果
那核心来讲的话
特效系统的话呢
我们有两大盘
一大盘呢就是粒子系统
还有一趴呢是我的声音系统
其实这个都是大家很熟悉喜闻乐见的东西了
比如说像粒子系统
像这个是星战的游戏
你们的这个效果怎么样
看上去还是非常酷吧
因为像这种只要塞F对
就SAFI
就是科幻的类型的游戏的话
其实粒子系统是个非常关键的一个系统
它几乎这个成就了我
我们游戏的整体的这种质感的东西
都靠它来去表达这种打击感呀
这种这种效果感都要靠它拉满
那么粒子系统的话呢
其实是一个非常重要的系统
这里面我们讲鬼泣对吧
像那个老头环
还有像我的这个这个就是啊这几个
其他的像在下面的游戏
我就不一点名了吧
但是的话我突然脑子里反应为
我突然想把那个什么那个翻译翻译过来
我突然翻译我翻译不过来了
那个对马老师混啊
不是代码混
脑子晕了
没玩法打铁
Ok anyway
就是说其实啊在我们以前在做游戏的时候
我开个玩笑
就是比如说我们要玩很多的网游的话
你很多时候你的付费都是为特效付费的
为什么就是你发现你充实
让你的角色变得越来越强的话
它本质上就是把以前那个一个大剑
砍出去的粒子再做大一倍
做大两倍而已
对大家回想一下
是不是以前傻乎乎的
充个648得到的效果
是不是就这样的一个变化
所以说粒子系统有的时候我们开玩笑
就是啊
是游戏里面这个变现能力最强的这种游戏系统
当然了
我们是做游戏引擎技术的
另外一个就是
我个人还是比较推崇做这种3A型游戏
所以说的话呢
粒子系统更多的是跟游戏的内容去表达
但这一年反向的也能说明一件事情
就是说其实粒子系统的话对这个游戏的表现力
角色的打击感
游戏的game play
其实是影响非常大的一个系统
那么今天的话呢
给大家介绍粒子系统的时候的话呢
我会先从相对简单的开始介绍起来
其实粒子系统啊
它最早定义的时候是在电来自于电影行业
并不是这个游戏行业
就是最早的粒子系统引入的话
那是1982年的这个星
那个星际迷航里面的那个
就是那个可汗之怒那里面的
他他当时做那个效果
他说所有这种fuzzy object它定义了一种叫proc system
就是管他的整个产生以及生命周期中的动画
以及整个生命周期的管理
然后呢
这个的文章呢就出现在了191983年
就第2年的这个c rap上面
就是那个呃那个就是那个transaction graphics
这是我们在图形学领域大名鼎鼎的一个杂志
我们早年都是这个还是图形学的
这个这个我们就皇冠上的这种杂志吧
我们一直都是以他为为荣的
那么上面最早定义了这个party system这个概念
那么其实呢到后面
游戏行业逐渐的越来越复杂的时候
我们就引入了粒子系统
这个我应该大概率应该是在3D游戏时代之后
粒子系统就会越来越普及
那么其实一个particle就是一个粒子
它首先我们讲party system
它最基础的构建元素是什么呢
是一个粒子
那一个粒子
它你可以理解成
这空间中一个小点或者一个小面片
我的有什么东西
然后呢你可以看到它有几个基本的属性
比如说它的位置啊
它的速度啊
它的尺寸啊
它的颜色啊
包括他现在的他现在生命周期啊
它比如说它已经产生了五秒钟还是六秒钟对吧
这就是一个很简单很直觉的
比如说我们想象一下
我们一个锤子打下去会蹦出很多火花
那每个火花就是个粒子
对不对
所以说这其实是一个非常好理解的一个东西
那么每一个粒子呢其实它是有一个生命周期的
生命周期中的话呢
它首先被spawn出来
就是被创生出来
然后呢它有一个运动的属性
比如它有个速度对吧
然后呢它各种颜色也会变化
同时呢它还会跟环境的那个互动
比如说我撞到一个东西会反弹
比如说我会受到风力的影响
我会受到重力的影响
然后呢诶他还有个生命的lifespan
就是说它的生命的这个寿命
它的寿命到了寿命它会自动消灭掉
否则的话你不断产生粒子系统的话
这个粒子如果没有死亡的话
整个游戏环境里面的这个粒子会不会越来越多
那这样整个系统就跑不动了
其实粒子系统很容易写出的bug
就是粒子的这个这个生命周期没管理好
导致系统崩啊
系统的资源消耗殆尽
所以这其实就是一个最最简单的一个
粒子的生命周期的管理
那么这个时候呢我们还有一个很有意思的东西
就是image
就是粒子的发射器
大家想象对吧
就是想象一下
就是我的这个这个粒子
就从一个小发饰
心里的不断腾腾腾腾腾就扔出来
扔出各种各样的小球
然后每个小球呢
它又有自己的刚才讲的那些属性
它就会形成自己的运动轨迹
那发射器会给他一些什么呢
有的时候会给他一些随机的初始值
比如说我要表演
我要表演一个像喷泉的东西的话
那我的粒子它发射的时候
初速度不能够是同一个速度
对不对
它之间速度大小是有一个小小的随机
然后呢它的方向有点小小的cg
这样你看上去像一个喷泉的效果
所以IMMETER真的是
这也是非常好理解的一个概念
其实今天的整个talk的话
一开始的这几part都比较简单的
非常的直观
很很容易很容易理解
然后呢
诶当我们把很多个IMMETER放在一起的时候
我们叫做一个system
就是system粒子系统
你可以理解成就是这些image在一起的组合
当然了
其实更严格的讲的话
是这么多的image和它发射出来的所有的party
在正在活着的
或者已经还在管理中的party的一个总和
那么实际上为什么我们要定义一个system呢
因为你会发现在游戏中
我们真正的表达一个效果
比如像这里面一个火焰燃烧的效果
我们实际上是有很多种不同的particle的
比如说我要有那种就是火焰的本身比较大
比较暗的这种比较亮的这种party
就表示我的火焰对吧
那火焰从火的根部出来到中间开始变得最亮
然后再叠加到上面也逐渐暗淡下去
那么我上面还有一些飞着的火星
火星又是一名particle
它的轨道又不太一样
还有什么呢
还有烟对吧
你看这三种东西合到一起
才能形成一个看上去很真实的一个火的效果
其实同学们去看一下游戏中的那种啊
特效的话
其实就是用这种组合方法给它做出来的
那么再举个例子
比如说一个一个最简单的是这个这个石头的
就是被击中了
这个一个弹药击中了石头爆炸的这么一个粒子
你可以发现它实际上也是有诶
直接击中的时候冲击的那一下的烟尘对吧
往四周扩散的这种
这个比较四散的这种这种炸开的东西
还包括很多碎片
DEBRICK这种碎片形成
所以说其实我们的effect artist
就是特效艺术家的话
它最核心的研究的就是这个组合怎么样子
我们在真实世界里看到了一些这种效果之后
我怎么用一个一个简单的系统组合
来生成我们想要的效果
这就是粒子系统
非常有意思
其实也是非常好的理解
那么粒子系统的话呢
实际上它的那个particle sport
实际上如果image它只是在一个点上的话
我们其实是最常用的一种image
对不对
但实际上呢我的IMETER可以做的更复杂
比如说我可以限定一个空间的区域
比如说我希望你在一个box的这个空间
或者一个SFA的空间
或者是capital的空间去生成我的particle对吧
当然我开的速度
这样我的形成各种各样复杂的形状
那我甚至可以拿一个mesh
就是比如像这里面一个洞的这个人
我在他身上采样
然后用他身上采样出来的随机点生成我的party
这可是形成一些更酷炫的效果
所以其实拍这个系统啊
对于比如说啊不仅是对游戏啊
其实对于影视后期特效行业来讲
那都是一个最最重要的一个一个关键性系统吧
所以我们经常讲那个啊一个电影的特效
做的不好
我们今天会说什么叫五毛钱的特效对吧
那这个这里面黑的东西是什么呢
就是说啊particle如果做得好
你会觉得他非常的效果增益
让你觉得很真实
很有感觉
如果发这个做的不好呢
你就感觉一群简单的面片满天飞
这就是啊展现出我的粒子系统设计的好坏
还有我的特效艺术家的水平高低
那个就在这地方体现出来
那么其实呢particle呢就是SPA的话呢
你会发现就是说它本身party sport
也有很多可以定制的东西
比如说我们可以让它连续的随机的哒哒哒哒
往外喷对吧
比如就比如说我刚才讲了一个
喷喷泉的这种案例
那么它也可以变成什么呢
就是说哎periodic
就是说我到了一定时间随机的碰突然爆发
1111批出来
那这样的话你根据你要表达的效果不同的话
在EMOR这边的话
你其实可以设置各种各样的不同的
这个它的行为模型
那么当我们这个span就是那个image spawn了很多
particle出来之后
这个particle在这个空间上的这个所有的行为
我们叫什么呢
我们叫做simulate
就是模拟
那就simulate的话呢
他首先要模拟就是说我的particle
每一个particle出来
它受到的各种各样的立场的作用
比如说它受到重
一定
很多时候我们要考虑它受到重力的作用对吧
他要受到重力还说了什么呢
空气阻力对不对
还有什么呢
还有风的扰动
比如说大家玩那个对马岛之魂的时候对吧
最有印象的不就是信仰之风嘛
对不对
那么信仰之风的话
他那个就是说就是模拟那种particle
沿着风吹的那个方向的那种感觉
给你指引方向
所以这三个是我们particle最常受到的力的影响
那么其实的话呢就是在simulate的时候呢
其实就跟我们之前在讲那个啊物理那一趴
很接近
就是说我每个particle呢
你可以认为就是一个非常小的物理的质点
那么他大家还记得我们那那节课上讲了
各种各样的时候显示积分
影视积分办理时积分对吧
whatever你用什么
其实粒子系统还好
因为它不是需要严格的物理准确
所以说一般来讲大家就是用最简单的显示积分
就可以了
然后的话呢就是我们每一帧根据当前的速度
根据我受到的力决定我下一帧的这个决定
我受影响的速度和下一帧的位移速度方向
就一点一点的把它记下来
其实就非常简单
那么这个过程中我正在形成这种一个喷泉啊
或者是往上撒的这种炸弹的爆炸
或者一些各种各样的奇怪的效果
其实这个效果做的其实可以非常的真实
那么其实当我们在
但在这个赛季simulation的过程中呢
其实我们扰动的不仅仅是它的位置速度
还有什么呢
还有他各种各样的这个这个其他的参数
比如说我要让它旋转起来
这样看上去是更真实对吧
那我们还可以什么呢
我看还可以改变它的颜色
就是它的颜色在过程中间可以一直在变
比如刚才我们讲了一个火焰
你在做那个火焰的时候
那个particle产生出来的时候
它一开始的颜色可能是暗红色
到中间的时候是温度最高的时候变得发亮
然后再飞得更高一点的时候
因为温度损失得很厉害嘛
它就会变得暗
这样的话你能感感感觉产生了一个火的效果
其实严格来讲的话
火焰在不同的高度
它的颜色都是不一样的
大家还记得我们学过黑体辐射对吧
就不同温度的这个辐射体的颜色都是不一样的
那么包括呢它的尺寸
因为很多东西它在扩散
比如像烟
我们做它的particle的时候
他一开始是浓密的小小的
然后呢慢慢越来越扩散越大
它的它越来越淡
但是呢他的覆覆盖的空间的范围越来越大
所以这些参数的变化
都是我们在做simulation的时候最重要的一个计算
那么这个计算呢一般在早期的PC系统来讲
其实非常简单
基本上都预先设定好
然后交给artist调整一下它的参数基本够用了
但现在拍这个系统的话呢
已经变得越来越复杂了
那么更复杂的就是说我们还希望这个particle啊
他在simulation的时候还和环境有互动
举个例子
就是说我们在人的认知中
我们总是会认为你喷出去的这个粒子遇到了
比如说有些障碍物的时候
它会被反弹
它会被阻挡
对不对
那么这件事情呢
如果我们直接调用物理系统的话呢
实际上会非常的慢
但是呢你想一下
就是说像我们一个系统
动辄就撒出几百个甚至上千个particle
那我们对它的模拟的话呢
就需要一种非常高效的物理碰撞检测算法
后面会讲的细节
但是呢其实对整个世界的collection
也是这个系统非常重要的一个属性要求好
那么这个simulation的过程的话
就构建了整个particle的生命周期的管理
那么particle的话呢
每个出来之后
其实大家想象的它并不是一个抽象的一个质点
那么particle是什么呢
particle一般来讲有各种各样的形态
那么最常用的形态是什么呢
最常用的是bear world bebo这个词呢
呃翻译成中文不知道怎么翻译了
反正就是它就是一种使
就是你做一个面
一个阔的他始终朝向你的camera
就是无论你camera怎么转
这个b bot总是嘲笑你
我们做的这个事例
同学们把camera freeze freeze出了
就告诉你说
你现在看到这个火和烟
它其实是一群永远朝向你的这个party面的
但是呢这个单位会让大家有点误解
实际上应该做的是
我无论怎么转
你总是会觉得那个particle总是朝向我的这一点
为什么是它是有用的
因为在真实的在做particle的时候
我们那个那个每个party的颜色和外观一直在变化
所以呢你可能会被那个变化吸引走
你注意不到说那个particle一直朝着你的转
如果那个particle是一张静态的图的话
它假如它的阿尔法它的内容不发生变化的话呢
大家其实是非常容易意识到
就是说这个particle是由一个永远朝向camera
camera的比尔波的构成
所以这个是啊我们在做PC系统的时候
一个小trick
就是说你在做particle
如果做b bot的时候呢
如果这个particle本身尺寸很小
那你没关系
用一些颜色
有些简单的东西你能表达
如果这个part比较大的话呢
我们一般建议你用animate texture
就是说它的那个外观总是随着时间在变化
这样的话就是作为用户来讲
不会注意到说你是用很多小面片
模拟空间中的一种体量感的东西
所以这是一个非常有意思的一个小trick
那billboard的particle呢
实际上是particle系统
最经典也是最古老的一个东西
就是基本上你可以认为就是早期的particle系统
基本上讲的就是比ba particle
但是呢随着游戏变得越来越复杂的时候
我们就发现不够了
比如说我们要表现各种各样的小的
这种碎屑的时候
那你可能要模拟很多的小的这种碎片钢铁
所以有的时候我们用MARMESH直接作为particle
那这里面注意注意一下
就是说这些mesh的话呢
一般来讲需要有一些随机性
最简单的一个随机啊
就是假设我做不了很多REMARCH怎么办
诶我把每一个match的T把它转个角度
然后把它大小放缩一下
甚至会做一些XYZ方向呢随机的放缩
这样也能让你产生一种它的不一样的感觉
注意大家在做PC系统的时候
我们一般都会追求一种随机感
尽量避免一种重复感
所以这里面的话呢是我们在设计作为引擎
去提供PC系统的时候
你会发现你最重要的是给artist提供各种随机的
可调整的量
他们特别喜欢在里面说
诶
你给我告你把所有的变量都允许我随机一下
这样的话我做出的效果看上去才会自然和真实
那么第三种呢
particle呢也是一种大家可能比较少见
但其实在游戏中非常常用的一种particle
我们叫做ribbon
Ribon particle
或者有的人叫做ban particle
他的意思是什么呢
就是你的这条particle
它脱出的是一条光带
大家想象一下这个particle什么叫有用啊
实际上是在这个打个比方
比如说我们在游戏中打出一条这个一根
那一根很厉害的这个加了魔法的剑
那个箭的尾迹在空中
是不是打出了一条漂亮的抛物线的那个丝带
而当你有很多很多人这样去做的时候
是不是就形成了一条一条的袋子
这种东西就是ribon particle
那么rain particle呢
它的它的核心的点是什么呢
就是这个particle在飞行的过程中啊
它会不断地拉出一个一个一个额外的控制节点
然后呢他认为我是应该有一定宽宽度
把这一个个的控制点连接在一起的
这样一个绶带
这个东西在很多我们在control
比如说轨迹对吧
或者我刀剑划过去的一道弧度
上面是非常有用的
基本上我们在游戏里面
要表现出一些空间的这种时空滞留感
比如打出一个气功弹对吧
一个一个气功波打出去
这也是一个很典型的ribbon text啊
BON那个particle
那么rain particle的话呢
他实际上呢有一个小小的挑战
就是说如果我们只是把这一个个的离散点去
我们连接在一起的时候
你会发现我们连出来是一条一折一折一折的线
所以呢当我们真的在去实现这个ribbon
particle的时候的话呢
我们一般会采用样条曲线差值
大家在前面的动画系统啊
物理系统啊
还有更前面的rendering系统里面
应该对我们的样条曲线
应该是这个非常熟悉了吧
那这里面给大家小小的科普一下
一般来讲在做ribon particle的时候
他们我们一般会用cut more曲线
那为什么用cut more曲线呢
第一个就是cut more曲线比较简单
大家还记得cut more曲线就是一个啊
应该是个二三阶还是二阶的
一个一个PANORMAL的公式就可以直接插出来
那么第二个的话呢
它可以严格的保证你插出来的这条曲线
是通过所有的控制点的
所以呢这样的话呢
我只要在这个控制点之间再插入若干的点
形成一小节一小节的这个transition的话
那整个这个特效看上去就会圆滑很多
所以的话呢这个当我们去大家做游戏引擎
如果你要做project系统的话
一般来讲你提供这三类
比如说bill board
这个mesh和ribbon particle
按照刚才我讲的
就是你要加入一些尽可能多的这个随机扰动
然后呢你做ribon particle的时候
一定要注意加入那个cat more的这个插值曲线
让这个texture
让这个这个插值出来的shape看上去性能的平滑
那你基本上就可以做一个简单的小的游戏引擎
用的PC系统了
其实十几年前啊
我们在做帕克系统的时候
差不多也就这些东西就够用了
那么其实呢这个系统的话呢
它从基本原理上来讲非常的简单对吧
当然我的我的强调一下
我在前面这一趴讲的party系统
都是最基础的party系统
但是因为这门课还有些门基础课
所以给大家讲的就是最经典的
particle系统的核心要素
那么其实呢就是这么简单的party系统
当我们真的去做他的绘制的时候
你会发现我们有很多的挑战
那你们最大的一个挑战是什么呢
哎我的老朋友又来了
大家还记得我们在讲rendering pipeline的时候
我就讲过
就是说其实啊透明物排序是我们游戏渲染中的
挥之不去的一个噩梦
因为它非常的就是你非常的这个非常的
这个常用
就是到时你到时候你都会用到
但是呢如果你做不好或者做的效率特别低的话
效果就会一塌糊涂
就觉得像这个粒子里面
就是说如果你一次看这些透明我的话
那你排序的和没有排序的结果的话
看上去感觉是完全不一样的
那么它核心的点就是我的画
透明物永远是要从最远的那个透明木画的
最近的一个透明
我这样一层层的覆盖
这样的阿尔法布兰妮的结果才是正确的
如果我的顺序是乱的
其实我产生的结果也会是乱的
人的眼睛一眼就能看得出来
那么这样的话对于系统来讲的话
这就是个超级大的问题了
因为大家想象一下
在场景里面我去做一些玻璃墙
做什么东西
我大不了做个几十块也就不得了了对吧
那我去那个绘制它的时候
实际上也还好
这个排序我还能排得出来
而且每一个范围基本能够控制
但是大家想象一下这个系统
我在游戏中动辄就能产生几百
上千个这样的一个beer board
那我怎么去排他们前后关系呢
那么这里面呢就有两大流派
第一大流派呢就是说哎我全局的进行排序
就是说我不管你是用哪个particle系统
哪个em特性的particle
你比如说有的有的
有的系统产生了50个particle
我的系统产生了100个party
我的系统产生70particle
我把你们这200多个particle全部合到一起拍
就像这里面的粒子就是绿色的
是一个immature existence
红色是ISTENCE
他们之间的话对于每个particle来讲
他们之间是交叠的
那没关系
我就自己按顺序排
那这样我排出来的结果就是正确的
但是呢在真实的这个大家就知道
因为排序你越多的元素参与的话
它排序的成本就越高
而且因为我们每个派系统绘制的时候呢
实际上我们有很多参数的设置都是要求一致的
那你这样的话来回跳的绘制啊
其实成本很高
实际上在很多的particle系统里面的话
我们只能按EMETER进行排序
就是说诶你这个在前在后
那这样的话两个靠得非常近的IMETER
就会产生什么问题呢
就会产生这样的
就是说哎你看虽然其实真实的情况
绿色的particle和红色的particle之间有很多胶底
但是你现在看上去好像所有的绿色都在前面
因为绿色的那个IMETER可能靠相机稍微近一点
这其实是我们在party系统非常常见的一个问题
就是如果你们看一些早期的游戏啊
他经常就是当你的相机发生动的时候
你会发现比如说有些smoke column就是烟柱
还有一些什么特效
它会突然一下就闪动了
这这种情况下一般就是particle sorting出了问题
但是如果今天大家在写游戏引擎的话
特别是入门的话
我会建议大家先不要去写那个global的那个shot
因为那个写起来比较麻烦
而且后面会讲到一些GPU更复杂的一些算法
你先写一个最简单的per imeter sorting的话
能够解决你部分的问题
但是这个锁定它如果不解决
产生的后果是非常严重的
比如这里面这个粒子
里面那个就是那条带子的那个ribbon
它就是一个particle
它实际上是穿过这些particle我的眼中间而入的
但是因为他的bounding volume
是总是在靠近最靠近相机的
所以它会被排序到最后
所以你会觉得那个那个光标它是穿过
就是浮在所有的烟之上
那么你再看下面一个例子
就是如果我用global shooting的话
我就是把这个ribbon的每一节
和你的这个particle进行排序的话
你会发现诶看上去好像现在的结果就对了
所以大家看看
所以说其实transparency的物体的排序和渲染
其实是游戏引擎里面特别要仔细去处理
随着现在的这个游戏
它的环境越做越复杂
真的就是我们很多游戏里面那种气氛感
都是有大量的particle
大量的我们叫做ambient的东西让你感觉出来了
比如说我们举个例子
比如说我们表达一个一个你到一个地方去
这个环境的感觉
你可能在那走
你没有意识到
但是我为了让你觉得这个环境是真实的
你的脚下可能有几千上万个那种大气的
微微扰动的particle在那流动
所以你会觉得这个地方的空气
就这个地方环境是活的
是有很多互动的
包括你的脚走出的每一步
风吹过来的落叶
天上这个一些鸟雀在飞
这些东西才让你觉得这个世界是真实的
所以说一个好的游戏和坏的游戏
其实对于这种particle系统的依赖度
其实差别是非常非常大的
就我们讲高质量的游戏的话
那么其实的话呢
particle系统的sorting的话是是一个挑战
另外一个还有很大的挑战是什么呢
这也是大家很多时候
我经常会意识不到的一件事情
就是说其实啊那个系统看起来非常的简单
只是一些简单的诶
每一个粒子这样移动来移动去移动来取
但是呢它很多时候是我们游戏的性能杀手
为什么呢
我们绘制透不透明的物体啊
无论这个世界多复杂
我们只需要绘制最后一个像素
什么意思
就是说当我一根视线看过去
我可能看到非常多复杂的几何层次
对不对
但是呢我有一个叫z buffer
z buffer会把所有后面的最后面的东西全部滤掉
只留下最靠近我的眼睛的那个点
然后呢我对它进行shading
特别是deer的shading
就是说我所有的屏幕上
比如说100万个像素点
我只需要设定一四
但是当我们去绘制透明物的时候
但是透明物呢
如果这个透明物来自于环境还好还好
因为你一根视线看过去的话
那你顶多也就看到过
比如说七八个透明物就不得了了
但是party system那简直就是丧
就是这个怎么说呢
我称之为叫trouble maker
就是说你面前有一个烟的一个爆炸
然后呢
其实在你眼面前迅速就可以怼出几十个
甚至上百个
有你整个屏幕那么大的这个particle
然后所以我们以前经常叫做overdraw
就是说同一个像素我被绘制了多少次
那大家想想看一个屏幕大小的particle
它就是1100多万个像素点对吧
那么我怼他个就是几十个甚至上百个的时候
那就是几个亿甚至十几个亿的计算量级
那其实你会发现游戏的帧率就会迅速的下降
所以其实在游戏中的话
它这个系统很多时候会把你的游戏的帧率
迅迅速的下降了
所以在现代游戏中的话呢
我们基本上会用的一个技术就是half resolution
什么意思
就是说哎我服了你了
你很厉害
那我怎么办
既然你是这种很faster的东西对吧
那我怎么办呢
哎我把屏幕的resolution整个减少一半
当然了
我要把z buffer也减少一半
然后呢我把你这些所有透明的物体
特别是particle全部在一
就是1/4的
就是那个像素数量就是half resolution
就是XY都缩小一半
它的总像素量是不是少了四倍
然后呢我把你这些透明物渲染上去
注意这里面有个细节
第一就是说
如果你的Z是在这个已经当仓破了
这bug之后的话
那就不需要绘制了
第二呢
你这些所有的particle的这个这个啊
这些透明物的这个这个算出来结果的话
一定要集体算一个阿尔法
然后呢
这个阿尔法再和我的这个就是前面的
OPAC的物体进行blending
当然我的blending的过程是一个up的过程
这里面做一些简单的差值
一些变化
一些扰动
我就能得到一个非常不错的效果
其实在游戏引擎里面
现在越来越多的这个渲染
我们已经开始用half resolution了
这个好处是什么呢
就是说我们会发现在现在游戏里面
随着我们游戏显示器的分辨率越来越高对吧
之前是1080P
我讲的是大概啊差不多有200多万那个像素
如果是4K的话
那就是差不多接近1000万的像素对吧
我们后面还有8K的显示器不得了
那就那个像素量就特别大了
就是说即使在现在超强的GPU的话
我们也做不到全尺寸的渲染
所以我们一定会用当山坡林的方法去做
当然了
这里面有讲到了著名鼎鼎的
比如大名鼎门
像大力水手DRSSR
就是其实up sampling down sampling的
就是用低精度的绘制
然后再用一些算法把它放回系统网站
其实是现在渲染里面一个非常常用的一个技术
那么当然在帕克斯里面的话呢
希望大家去写的时候一定要小心
就是说它非常容易出现
就是你觉得一个很简单的效果
突然把你的游戏的帧率就降下来
但这里面我们还有一些更更多更复杂的算法
比如说以前我们在做PC系统时
如果我们发现这些particle离相机特别近的时候
我们会cut掉一些particle
就是或者说我们用一些其他的方法
就是降低那种就是在同一个像素点上
重复化的这个particle的数量
这也是一个非常重要的
particle系统的一个功能好
那么讲了这么多的话
其实part6系统的话
它最大的问题
无论是绘制
其实还有一个它的本身
simulation对效率的影响也特别大
因为对于现代游戏来讲的话
我们很容易在一个场景里面
可以达到几万甚至是上10万的帕克数量
我们才能产生我们想要的这样的一个效果
那么这么多的particle
我的每一帧都要对它进行各种各样的这个
计算处理
实际上对于CPU来讲是一个很重大的负载
那么大家想想
这种东西是不是天在我的rendering讲过GPU
对不对
GPU是干什么用的
GPU是不是特别善于处理这种海量的并发的东西
所以呢这个时候大家就很自然地想到说
诶我能不能把这个系统直接扔到GPU上去管理
但是呢particle它有一个比较复杂的东西
是什么呢
它有个生命周期
就是说它不是说一直在那算
而他每时每刻都会有新的particle产生
也会有很多particle死亡
那这里面的话
我怎么在这样一个简单的GPU硬件上
实现了它的模拟呢
那我在这节课的话呢
不讲不讲的特别细
但是给大家讲一个基本的概念
所以同学们如果有兴趣的话
自己想写part这个系统
我会建议就是大家写两套
先去写一个CPU的particle
接下来呢
按照我接下来这个课里面讲的这个思路
也尝试写一个GPU的版本
其实GP版本蛮有趣的
那么首先的话呢我们去想说唉
我们怎么把这个pk系统放到GPU上去
你会发现有很多很多的好处
比如说第一个我肯定可以用GPU的并行化的算力
对不对
另外一个就是说我去读z buffer
我去对frame buffer进行各种各样的处
理和计算的时候
实际上不用再把以前的z buffer再去读回来
进行处理
我直接可以全部的在这个就是GPU
你全部搞完
所以这是一个最简单的GPU particle的一个框架
对大家会发现他所有红色的区域
以前是在CPU里做的
现在全部移到了GPU
那它具体怎么做呢
其实他的思路非常的简单
第一个呢我们会定义一个叫particle pool
这个铺呢大家想想看
就是诶我用一串标准的数据结构
描述了所有的particle的描述数据
比如说你的位置
你的速度
你的颜色
你的尺寸
你的其他的一些meta的information对吧
比如说你的texture uv
whatever好
我定义一个标准的数据结构
那我假设我的整个系统的容量最多的容量
10万个particle在我的系统里面去
然后呢我再管一个东西是什么呢
叫做DEADLIST
就是说这个是我的上限
那我现在所有的一个part都没有
那我的DL是满的对吧
我再存一个值叫deadlist count对吧
就是我说哎我现在有这个这里面举个例子
假设是八个
然后呢我还有一个什么呢
还有我现在需要活着的party list
现在一开始是空的
但这个时候
当我一个image在GPU里面产生了particle的时候
哎我假设产生了五个particle
这个时候呢我就从那个DEADLIST里面
从尾巴开始去取五个空位出来
大家想想这是不是一个标准的一个
就是这个这个这个一个链表的插入
这个这个插入和那个释放的操作
对不对
我我是啊
这个这应该是个是个队列
就始终从它尾巴上去取它的数据
应该是个站吧
应该是个站
我使用松尾尾巴取数据
然后呢我塞到我我的列表里面去
这样的话我三四我就取了3456号particle
说是活的
我把数据填上去了
然后呢DEADLIST里面只有三个数据了
这样我就知道现在有活的particle了
然后这个时候呢我在GPU里面
假设我的时间take又往前走了一步
我就开始算了
我的哪个particle活
哪个particle死
我发现当然了
我首先要看我的所有活着的particle
我的particle不用管
我所有的活的particle进行一次simulation
我发现诶6号particle已经死了
那怎么办
那我从就把6号particle加到dead list里面去
同时的话呢其实呢我对particle那个active
那个alive list0啊
其实进行traverse的时候
我同时在写下一个friend lilist
我的叫做alive list1
这个时候呢如果我认为我的自己还是活着的
比如像345我的没问题
我就三写一个一下五
四写一个一下
五写一个一下
当我去similate party6的时候
发现六六死了
那我把6appended到DEADLIST上去
同时的话呢我就skip掉
往LEVELIST1里面去写六这个编号
然后呢接下来我再走七
这些东西在CPU上写的是很好写的
对不对
但是在GPU上好不好写呢
在以前的GPU上是很难写的
但是自从有了computer shader之后
这事就变得非常的简单
因为computer shader提供了一个就是原子操作
就是你可以在一个一组计算中
我可以设置一个就是全局变量
这个其实它叫一个局部变量
然后呢啊我们可以保证它的原子性
我的就是说我我虽然是BACHELLE在运行
但是当我去读写那个变量的时候
我们都是保证它的原子性的
所以这是确实是COMPUSHA一个很好的一个属性
所以这样的话
我实际上用了一个简单的双8buffer的这个策略
就可以每一个tick在GPU中啊
在那个就是那个computer shader
其实也是GP了
computer shader中算出来每一个particle
它的生命周期的变化和它的属性的变化
然后呢
把它反向的更新到我们活着的这个particle
列表里面
和死的particle列表
这样呢我再做个buffer swaring
我就得到了下一帧我要绘制的particle
那么接下来我在做一件什么事情呢
因为我的这些数据全在GPU了
对不对
接下来呢我还能做一个更大的一个优势
就是说我可以在里面做view frost calling
那为什么这件事情再做起来就非常的方便呢
因为啊其实view first colin呢
也是个非常简单的计算机
它特别适合用GPU去算
那么我这样的话就可以得到一个所有visible的
就是说可见的particle的列表
这样的话
我又进一步减少了我要绘制的列表的数量
但这里面有个细节啊
同学们说诶为什么我view russian calling那个alive list
他不会反向的去改变alive list
这是为什么呢
因为其实一个particle是死是活啊
他跟你看不看
但是没有关系的
大家想想看
比如说我这边射出了一群一群烟火
你不去看它
它还在空中飞
对不对
当你回头去看他的时候
如果你因为上一帧看不见它
你把它从那个活的列表中给干掉的话
一回头的时候是不是他就没有了
是不是该产生了一些很奇怪的效果
所以的话呢
就是接下来的计算全是view dependent了
也就是说particle simulation是跟view是没有关系的
所以你simulation出来
所有在在我的周围环境中活跃的particle
我会再做一个单独的叫view fluster calling
我就把你这些particle给你给取出来
然后接下来我还做一件什么事情呢
诶我还可以去做这个跟depth buffer进行这个
进行这个比较
同时呢我还要做什么呢
我还要去做他的这个就是sorting
Sorting
我也全在GPU里面做
但是我会讲sorting的细节
然后这个时候我基于这个alive的particle的话
我声称我要我要去渲染用的vertex和index buffer
这样这个这个地方的话呢有很多小细节
但这些细节我相信同学们自己研究一下
都知道怎么去写
所以这其实就是个GPU
particle系统的一个非常简单的一个思想
其实这个思想很好用
非常好用
其实你们在做任何的
就是这种集群性的这种运算啊
这些这个东西的话都可以按这个思路进行管理
因为你一上来构建一个P
知道我所用的计算的上限
然后呢用一个LIVELIST
就是活的active的这些东西的列表
就指向一个它的数据的index
然后呢哪一些被recycle
就是我们叫dead list
就是死亡的列表
然后这两个列表之间的index来回swap
来回交换的时候
就能够完成一个对一个很动态的系统的管理
这是一个非常常用的一套结构
那这里面就讲一个细节
就是因为我的product系统最难的东西是什么
是排序对吧
sorting就是我们刚才讲了
如果你不排序的话
而且我们希望的是什么是global sorting
这么多particle
我们要在全局的排个先后
那以前这些数据都是在
就是在这个就是我的组组内存上
然后我的CPU是可以排序的
那就是用我们在数据结构里面教的最简单的
比如快速排序法呀
什么什么这个这个这个冒泡排序法对吧
N平方当然没有人会用冒泡排序法了
那么哎我们还是能排序的
但是现在问题是我到了GPU上
我怎么排序呢
那这里面的话呢其实有很多很好的算法
我这边给大家讲几个最经典的一个思路
就是叫mega salt merge
Salt
merge salt的话呢
他的想法其实非常简单
就是就是我们在学排那个排序的中
有一个方法
就是我们把一个大的数列的排序
分解成无数个已经排好序的数列的整合的过程
也就是说
比如说我第一步把所有相邻的两个元素
大小排序排好
我就得到了无数个小小的已经排好序的数列
对不对
然后呢这个时候我在每两个一组一组合
因为你那边已经排好序了
所以呢
我其实把你二进四的时候就会非常的简单
这里面你会发现就是我这个排序的时候
只要用log n的时间就可以了
然后我四进八的时候
因为你两个独立的四的数列也也好
其实我每一次每个地方我选取一个元素的时候
我只需要我自己的
这个时候我自己数列也不用找了
因为我知道后面的数据一定比我大
我只要在你的那个数列中去查找呃
有哪些数据在我的前面
他怎么去
其实非常的简单
就是一个二分查找法就可以了
所以的话呢这种merge salt的思想是
每一步我的计算都是log n的
然后呢诶我整个这个计算的复杂度
其实就是那个呃
就是那个就是n log的一个一个计算
所以这个其实是一个非常快速的一个计算方法
那么回到回到我们在GPU上去做这件事情的话呢
你会发现有两种非常简单的策略
就是我得到了无数个数列
比如说我在问我的
就是我找到我的每一个元素的时候
比如在已经做得好的元素里面
我取一个放到我的
这个就是啊我的目标数列中的话
我会去问说我能不能放在这个位置
其实呢你只需要找你自己都不用比了
你跟别人去比
跟别人去比的话呢
你只要在别人那二分查找
如果你发现别人
那个上一次那个游标节点和你的节点之间
没有冲突的话
你就可以把它放上去
这个具体的算法讲起来就比较比较用语言讲
特别的麻烦
这个最好要画图
那么这里面的话呢
其实你会发现
就是说这个时候你的SHADER就可以写了
因为你每一个SHADER的话
其实就是对于每个数字
每个元素
他只需要自己去和另外的那个
就是source的那个数组里面做一次二分查找
就可以找到自己的点
那么这样的一依次找下来的话呢
你就能够得到最终一个已经排序好的节点
当然了
这里面其实是有一篇参考文献的
我这里就不不展开了
结果到时候我们在会后的话会把文献给大家
这个作者呢他就做了两个比较
他说啊其实在GPU中去进行这种sin的话
是一个很常用的操作嘛
那么左边的第一种方法的话呢
是一个非常符合人直觉的方法
也就是说我把两个source
已经排好的数组都变了一遍
然后呢这个过程中我就能得到我想要的结果
但是呢它会出现一个什么问题呢
就是说啊他在写的时候
它的地址是一直跳来跳去的
那么这个写的时候一直跳来跳去的话呢
会让这个magic coherence
a cash coherence降得非常低
他说如果你想象一个就是几10K
几十和几10K的东西进行排序的时候
这个内存跳起来就会非常的大
他说这个效率其实是非常非常低的
那么他所以推荐我的做法是什么呢
他反过来去算
他说我对于我的目标那个矩阵上的任何一个点
我在两个source的这个这个这个数列上的话呢
去寻找我该应用聊的那个元素
然后呢这个反向的去找
这样的话
我每次写的这个顺序就是12345
一路写下来
他说这种方法就是max2是更好的方法
具体的实现的话呢
同学们自己去研究一下
但它最核心的思想就是
如果给你两个已经排好序的数组
你怎样把它合成一个排过去的速度
这其实是以前的
就是merge排序法的一个最核心的一个一个思路
但是在GPU上的话呢
你需要考虑到就硬件实现上的这种可行性
那么基本上在行业里面我们用的比较多的话呢
是第二种方法
确实他可以依次的去往那个做得好的数字
你去写
而这个东西的话呢
又是我们在GPU上实现系统特别重要的
一个小的技术细节
但是同学们听不懂啊
没有关系
因为我这边其实我觉得我也没有讲清楚
因为具体的来讲的话
那真的就是一个数字
一个数字去移
让你去找那个数字
但是的话呢大家看了这个参考文献
看了他的PPT的话呢
应该大概就能明白我们这节课讲的这个算法诶
好像我们这个PPT
是我没有把参考文献放上去
我们下一我的课后给大家补上
那么其实呢
在其实当我们把整个这个particle放在GPU上
还有个好处是什么呢
就是说哎我们可以进行更复杂了
比如说我的碰撞
那碰撞
如果让每个粒子真实的和物理的这个引擎啊
大家还记得我们上节课讲物理引擎吗
都结算一遍
那个速度是很慢的
所以呢其实在行业里面
大家很多时候用的是什么呢
就是那个用我的death buffer
就是view dependent
就是用screen space这个深度
我们模拟出一个空间的这个几何形状
然后呢particle在这里面进行碰撞
所以呢我们直接从depth buffer里面去取它的值
然后呢跟这个就是particle进行碰撞
这个效果呢其实还是不错的
像这个结果就是一个典型的
用那个就是说screen space depth buffer
然后呢我们做这个碰撞
其实很多时候他肯定是远远好于没有
这个就是collision induction and particle
所以这part这个系统永远都是在效果和
这个就是计算效率之间
做trade off的这么一个系统
好
其实呢系统呢
我前面讲的这些都是比较基本的实现
比如像gp particle
现在已经基本上成为现代引擎的一个标配了
对吧
然后的话呢但是呢其实party系统它做的深的时候
有很多更复杂的应用
举个例子
比如说我们要展现一个人群
Crowd
就很多很多的这个这个人或者是鸟或者是动
其实大家以前觉得诶这是不是物体在上面走了
这其实呢在很多游戏产品中
我的引擎中提供的是一种particle
系统的这种能力
比如像这里面对吧
大家看到这些人跑来跑去
它其实就是product系统
那么这个东西它是如何做到呢
像这个是星战里面的一个demo嘛对吧
那么其实呢
它实际上把这些游戏里面的这些角色
变成一个个的就是mesh
这个mesh是一个particle
我的PC可以卖
注意啊
这个时候这个mesh的话不仅是一个mesh
它还是可以动的
我在每个顶点上我去存一个
它受控于哪个B
注意
这时候因为我是用particle所说的相对简单一点
所以我就不用那么复杂的skinny
所以我每个顶点的一般来讲我只存一个
就是影响我的BB
就是大家还记得我们在讲animation讲过
就是如果没有skinny的话
就是一个骨骼
就是每个顶点只受一根骨骼控制的话
我们会出现一些骨骼转起来就断裂对吧
不会像sky那样看上去那么真实
但是没有关系
因为就是你都已经那么小了这个particle了
我们不会注意到
就是当这样动的时候
这边会产生一个小小的裂缝
那么有了这样的一个就是skeleton
和那个就是最简单的skinny的information的时候
哎我们就可以把这个这个小小的particle
它所有可能的动画
就所有状态下的动画状态
1234567对吧
这个动画和在这个状态的时候
他比如他在他对他速度的影响
它是往前走
往后走
还是停止全部CODEC成一个texture
然后呢每个particle它不是一个simulation
simulation的话
我把以前一个简单的一个加减乘除
比如速度加减变成一个什么呢
变成一个状态机
就是每个particle的话呢
他在就是在自己的这个每个时间点
在状态机之间来回切换
这个时候大家发现没有
particle系统变得有点意思了对吧
不再是那么简单的
只是速度加位移加重力了
其实particle每个系统内部
就是每个particle内部
可以维持一个小小的状态机
这样的话它可以在这些状态中来回的切换
那我再做一个更复杂的
就是比如说我如何让它在这个世界上去
流动起来
那就最简单的说我给他一个速度
那所有的人都是往一个方向走
给一些随机
这个当然看上去是OK的
但是想象一下
如果我要我要表现这样的一个效果的时候
实际上呢我希望它是沿着道路去走
我不希望他走进建筑物
对不对
这里面的话呢它就会形成一个厂
这个厂是什么呢
就是我们前面讲过的SDF
就是这个就是带正负号的这个distance field对吧
就是有正负号的distant field的话
他就会告诉你说
哎你现在是在inner还是在外面
那么随着你的那个就值越来越接近零
我就知道你越来越接近某个障碍物
那么呢我这个我有了SDF之后呢
我可以算出整个场景比任何一个地方
它的这个空间的那个
就像一个道路一样的一个导向图
这个导向图的话呢我们叫做directional field
那么它只要存两个量就可以了
这个时候我给这个任何一个particle
就是一个角色有一个指引性
比如你在这个点sport
我说你应该去那个方向那么好
他就会受这个就像受了一股力的影响一样
就在这里面就开始飘起来了
然后你你在你看起来
你觉得这个人在动
当然了
我的particle的那个state machine里面的话呢
其实我会加入一些随机量
就是走到一半的时候
我会让他产生一些随机的状态切换
这个时候你在看到这个party的时候
就会觉得他真的非常的真实
这是一个非常有意思的东西
在这里面你可以看到这些角色
它会绕过这个障碍物
然后呢大体上往一个方向去走对吧
甚至我可以加入一些状态
就是哎如果我看到有其他的particle
我会相应的把它避开来
所以其实这个在crowd模拟的话
它最核心的底层系统的话是
就是particle系统的这样的一个一个方向
实际上这也意味着
就是part这个系统
和大家最开始的前面讲的那个过程
那个东西的话呢不太一样
就前面讲的其实是非常简单的
或者我们叫做古典的系统
而现代派系统的话呢
其实比大家理解的要复杂的多很多很多
那这里面举个例子
比如像这个例子
这个例子是我们取的unreal
最新的几个demo的粒子
其实我觉得做的是非常非常的好
就是你会发现就是mesh对吧
它可以从mesh变成一个image
形成很多的particle
然后经过一些控制的路径之后
他又回在这些party又汇聚成另外一个mesh
然后呢又产生很多的行为
然后呢我从一个可渲染的mesh
又把它打散成各种各样的一个一个一个碎片的
Particle
这些所有的动作其实它都是通过系统来实现的
那比如说讲一个更更有意思的
比如说像这种群体的模拟对吧
这个好像以前我们叫做swan这个系统
它其实也是用particle
jim particle呢
他会感知到主角的位置啊
环境的一些变化呀
去吸收一些环境的信号量啊
跟环境的几何会产生一些互动啊
这些其实在现代游戏中的话都是非常重要的
一些系统
所以大家去理解今天的游戏引擎的perk
系统的话呢
就是说实际上它的复杂度
已经远远超过我们最原始的一个理解了
那这里面的话呢给大家举一个简单的例子
比如做早期的park系统的话呢
我们做起来其实蛮简单的
就是哎我们预先设定好几种IMASTER的造型
然后每个IMETER开放各种各样的参数
让artist去控制
然后呢
我们在预先设定好各种各样的particle的类型
就是一个emit
你选择发射什么类型的particle
然后每一种particle我给你设定一个
比如说你是个mesh particle
你我就可以说诶你要用哪个几何
你对他哪些东西进行什么样的扰动对吧
然后你觉得产生影响的效果
如果你是ribbon的话
我就会说哎你的这个颜色变化是怎么变化呀
你的这个伪纪怎么个脱法呀
等等一大堆的东西啊
那么实际上就能产生很多我们想要的效果
通过这些imeter particle的组合
就能定义出各种各样的效果
但是呢在现代的游戏引擎里面的话
其实从每一个particle的simulation
就是一个PARTIC被打出去之后
他在这个生命周期里面
到底发生了什么样的一些变化
比如说它怎么样通过UV的变化
让你感觉那个particle一直在变形对吧
比如说我要读取环境变量
我需要知道我周围有没有一些啊扰动我的东西
或者说我周围最近的一个neighbor
particle是什么等等
这些变化的量其实都要读取
那么包括image本身
它其实也是要读取
也是可以去让用户自己定义的
所以这一点上的话呢
其实我们再看这个现在particle的系统的发展
就是这些同学们需要有所了解的
我个人认为就是做的最好的是虚幻引擎的
NIAGARA的这个最新一代的这个particle系统
因为他确实是把过去的那种
故我们基于stock base的这种particle系统
和完全基于这种脚本化的可视化图
脚本化的这种part6系统全部结合起来
虽然那个系统非常的复杂
同学们如果研究的话
就会发现他非常的复杂
就是我们做过一个分析
就是说整个ARA代码中将近有100多万行代码
就是这个系统
大家想象一下
就这么一个PARTIC系统
写了100多万行代码
大家想想这里面有多复杂
但是确实它对于现代游戏来讲的话
其实是非常重要的一个系统
所以这也是我们games104这个课的这个精神
就是说呃我们会把最基础的
最基本的概念叫告诉大家
同时的话呢我们也会告诉大家
就是说这个行业最前沿发展到什么方向
所以我个人觉得就是说
如果同学们真的想精专于particle系统的话
我觉得以这个系统NIAGARA系统为为蓝本的话
花个就是几个月
甚至半年的时间去深度钻研的话
我的收获是非常非常大的
这也是游戏引擎的一个灭一个有意思的地方
就是说他任何一个子系统都足够
大家钻研足够久
这是一个非常有深度的一个一个一个行业好
所以讲到这儿的话呢
基本上把我们游戏的啊
最重要的一个粒子系统讲完了
大家是不是有点觉得哎
没有想到原来粒子系统这么有趣
可以做这么多有趣的东西
确实是他可以做的东西非常非常的多
当然这里面我们也要感谢我的artist
其实在游戏公司里面有一个角色叫做
Technique artist
他们其实也
我认为他们也承担了非常重要的研发的角色
是在用他们的聪明才智
他们的想象力
使得我们这些工程师啊
就是越来越这个广阔的
越来越深入地意识到
就是这些底层系统它的可行性
它的可能性
所以的话呢其实粒子系统从它最早一九差不多
现在有30多年前
40多年前提出来啊
整整40年
1982年40年了
那么到今天的话发展的这么庞大而复杂
这里面确实有我们很多technical artist的贡献
所以差不多讲到这儿
我们的粒子系统基本上就讲清楚了吧
给大家就是浅尝即止
点到为止好
那接下来呢就给大家讲我的SD系统
这个其实受制于我们课时的安排啊
所以说我的特效系统只有一个课室
然后呢就是我们既要把粒子系统讲清楚
要把SN的讲清楚
其实实话实说
这两个这两趴都可以至少支撑一个完整的section
其实甚至两个两个section都是可以的
所以的话今天的话呢我在讲这个声音系统的话
对游戏来讲的话也只能是浅尝
就是讲到一些最核心的概念
让同学们有概念
就是说在游戏引擎中
声音它到底有多复杂
他到底承担了什么关键的一个角色
因为其实力粒子效果系统EFFEX4M的话
一般来讲粒子系统和声音系统是不分家的
就是很多效果系统到最后你一定是要挂生效了
没有生效
那个粒子我看上去就非常的假
对吧好
那我们就讲什么叫声音
那首先的话呢就是audio
对于声音对于我的游戏来讲的话
是一个非常重要的一个组成部分
它基本上是对用户对这个世界的认可感知
互动性对吧
包括情绪的带入
完全是依据声音
所以我个人一直都很
我认为在每年的一个TGA啊
上面有一个很重的奖
就是我的最佳音乐奖和最佳声效奖
因为这两个奖的话
其实是非常考验团队的水平的
就是而且好的这种游戏作品的话
这两个东西做的绝对是没有问题的
绝对是让你觉得哇
那个音乐让你一下子情绪就带进去了
那个音效真的让你身临其境
比如说以前让我印象特别深的
比如像DESPACE死亡空间对吧
包括像那个就是那个啊就是死亡搁浅的声音
包括像很多恐怖游戏的声音
确实你会发现那个sound engineer
就是生效工程师和sound designer
实际上是这些游戏的真正的灵魂
那么sound为什么这么重要呢
我给大家举个例子
就是大家看这里面这个视频
完全的安静对吧
大家觉得嗯这好像看上去是一个恐怖游戏
但是好像没有任何的感觉
这就是个就是一个镜头
但是我们把声音真的放出来的话
大家感受一下
我都不想停了
因为我特别喜欢那个带着别人玩恐怖游戏
因为我特别享受
看别人被吓的这个这个花容失色的样子对吧
这是所有男生的这个恶趣味
所以说实话就是我觉得那个就是声音
其实对游戏的影响是直接的
因为讲一个进化学的理论啊
就是人的大脑是从脑干开始发育的
那么脑干是什么呢
就是大脑最开始是感应
就是在这很古老古老的时代啊
实际上它并不是有思维的器官
它是个感应周围环境振动的习惯
所以我们对震动的感知是从脑脑干开始的
所以声音你会发现一个特点是什么呢
就是说他对你情绪的影响是最直觉的
我相信很多同学都有这样一个经验
就是如果我让你看一部电影
我把他的声音关掉
你看了之后
你其实会觉得很奇怪
你没有感觉的
但是如果我把画面关掉
只听声音
其实你脑子中是可以构建这种画面感的
这就是因为声音
它对人的这种认知的影响是更加fundamental
更加本本的呢
这也是我一直在讲
就是说在很多的游戏引擎设计中
大家会对audio这件事情不够不够重视
或者说在做游戏的时候吧
大家对audio不够重视
但是我认为真的一个好的游戏的话
声音是非常重要的
因为它实际上很多时候
相比我们做那种很炫酷的画面来讲啊
他真的是一个事半功倍的东西
其实很多好的游戏音乐都是没得说的
比如说像陈星汉的journey对吧
那个音乐一旦响起的时候
我的感觉就不一样了
所以说这一点的话真的非常的重要
那么声音的话呢
第一个亮你的感觉就是音量的大小
我们叫做volume对吧
那音量大小本质上你可以认为就是声音的振幅
那么我这边有一个小小的音频
大家感觉一下注意啊
有点刺耳
就大家可以感觉到这个声音的大小
在发生变化吗
这当然就是单一的曲子
所以你听着特别的难受
特别的单调
但这就是声音的基础
那么声音的音量是什么呢
其实呢它本质上就是你感受到的
空气中的压强的变化
声音其实它主体是一个纵波
就是空气被压缩弹开
压缩弹开一个纵波
当然了
这个纵波本身也会导致一定的横波
那么它其实在单位的面积
就会给你产生一定的压强对吧
那这个压强呢就是你感受到音量的大小
那么我们经常接触到的一个音量的单位
是什么呢
叫分贝
那分贝怎么来的呢
给大家讲一下
就是说其实呢分贝它是一个非常有意思的一个
始于我认为是人体认知的这么一个概念
就是说它首先定义了一个叫最小的分贝为零的
那个那个压强
最小人类能感觉到那个压强
那个压强它描述是什么呢
就是大概一个蚊子离你3米发出的声音
诶我跟你讲
我看到这一趴的时候
我是特别有画面感的
因为我夏夏天的时候经常被蚊子招惹
然后我就觉得嗯确实是3米之外
有蚊子向我靠近的时候
我就有感觉
我就特别想跳起来
一下子拍死他对
那就是我们人类能感知到最小的声音
你看到没有
进化还是很有道理的
就是让你建立的最低
低到的远程预警雷达的声音
那么它基于那个文字拍动
产生的空气压强下的那个声音啊
我们以它为基数
那其他的声音的话呢
以它进行那个就是log的对比
就每十倍我们一个台阶
然后这个台阶呢我乘上个21
也就意味着就是说分贝为零
就是3米之外文字的上翅膀对吧
那分贝为一是二是什么概念
就是那个声音产生压强的十倍对吧
那分贝为40就是100倍
那60就是1000倍
所以大家会发现就是上去的时候
等我到一
比如说120dB
人类人类能容忍的
那个听到了容忍的极限的时候
那基本上是他的大概是啊100万倍了对吧
那么其实它就形成了一个log为单位的
这样的一个压强
那么P0的话
它的压强大概是两二十
这个没有怕的这样的一个压强
所以其实这也是我们对声音的一个perception
就是它不是一个线性的
其实它是一个logo base的
这个还是蛮有道理的一件事情
就跟我们以前在学那个
比如大家知道地震地震地震的列强度对吧
它其实也是这个概念
就是诶我的每一级地震之间好像是能量
如果没记错
好像是差的是十倍还是20倍吧
反正就挺大的一个一个值
所以说地震差一级的话
其实它的力度会差很多很多的
它它能量会差很多很多
所以其实我们对我的感知也是这个
这是大家第一次真的理解了分配
那这个概念
大家会觉得哎
我们是不是在科普一个科学概念啊
不好意思
我们今天讲的是个游戏引擎的课程
我们我们当然会讲很多科学知识
但是呢这个东西对游戏引擎非常重要
因为你会发现我们在游戏引擎设计的时候
我们开放给我们的audio designers
声音设计师用了所有的工具里面
它不是调这个声音的VOLIN的
直接指他所有声音的volume
全部用这个分贝或者类分贝的这个数值表达
都是以20的log10次幂来表达
这样的话能符合人对声音的自然认知
这个是非常有意思的好
那么声音呢还有一个叫peach
就是我的这个声音到底是尖锐还是不尖锐对吧
那么它其实的话呢就本质上就是声音的频率
大家都知道就是频率越高
你听上去声音就越尖
那我们人耳能听到的什么
大概是20到五十五千赫兹
就这个是声音的一个范围
在这里给大家听一个
这个具体发生了变化
对不对
这其实就是升学的一个基础
就是我们听到所有的声音
就是由这些东西构成的
那么我们有了这些屁事之后呢
我们就想诶什么
我们就把这么多不同的这个这个频率的波
叠在一起
这个波的跌的跌的形式不同
就会产生一个东西叫什么呢
叫做音色
其实音色你可以认为是有很多的激波
就是那个叫OVERTM叠在一起形成的东西
比如同样一个调
我是用钢琴演奏的
我是用小提琴演奏的
我是用这个这个这个
这个这个其他的乐器出来的话
你看到的东西会完全不一样
举个例子
大家听这段声音
对吧
感觉到了吗
完全不一样
这就是我的音色
音色你可以理解的就是频率大家都差不多
但是呢我的波我其实叠的那个激波是不一样的
或者每个低波的那个权重是不一样的
跟你听到的不同的区别
那么好
其实呢这里面就讲一个
既然空气它是一个就是那个声音是一个纵波嘛
那当你去收缩的时候
假设我在给你发过来一个让空气舒张的波的话
这两个波之间会不会形成一个抵消呢
确实它就会产生一个非常有意思的抵消效果
这就是我的降噪耳机的原理
所以其实我们降噪耳机本质上就是把声波
他先侦测出空气中的声波的
这个这个这个这个face它的相位和它的波的强度
然后呢我加上一个位移
把它反向的位移给我打过去之后
哎
两个波及反向底下它可能不是一个反向位移
它的是个抵消
就是真的抵消
就是这样就形成了我们的降噪耳机的原理
其实这个在游戏中的用处其实用处不大
但是呢
我们顺便讲个比较有意思的一个科学概念吧
好上面讲的东西非常的理论啊
但是大家需要知道的是什么呢
就是在我们我们如果我们做一个游戏引擎的话
我们需要知道人的听觉的范围
我们会知道是说话是在一个相应的
这个就是说频率和它的
这个就是分贝的范围之内
那我们能听到的这个音乐在一个范围之内
然后呢
在我们听到的一个就是整个的音乐里面会更大
比如说我们听到一些环境噪音
比如一些爆炸声
那么它的分贝数和它的那个频率
在于更大的范围
这里面有个细节
就是说虽然我们人耳能听到的频率
我们说我们能识别的频率是20到50HZ
但是呢其实高于50HZ
比如说到了这个1万赫兹的时候啊
实际上人还是有所感知的
他虽然你听不见
但是呢它会扰动你听的音色
所以当我们去做电影或者做一些高水平的音
那个就声音录制的时候
实际上我们表达的声音的频率
是要高于5000HZ的
这个也是就是说
听觉是个很重要的一种心理感受
这种震动的感受的话
人体的感受是非常敏感的
那其实呢声音它在空气中是无限连续的嘛
那在我们游戏中的话
或者在我的计算机中的话
我们是要把声音从这个无限连续的信号
变成一个离散信号
就是我们要把它DIGITALIZE
那这里面就有一个很有意思的问题
就是说我们怎么去在这个就是游戏
在这个计算机上表达声音的
这里面就引入大名鼎鼎的就是那个啊就是PCM
就是这个叫什么呢
叫脉冲代码
这个调制器这种方法叫那个就是那个pose code
那么这里面他其实他的想法其实非常的简单
就是我对于你这种波动的信号
我的第一个进行采样
采样率来的数据呢
你还是个浮点型
对不对
无限精度好
我对它进行框架ALIZATION
就是把它变成一个可以存储的
定点型的这个数据对吧
那么好不一定是定点啊
我也可以用浮点数存储它没关系
我就反正把它存下来
第三个呢我要对它进行编码
编码的目的就是让他去压缩
让他去表达
那么这其实就是PCM一个最简单的思想
那么对于声波这个东西呢
大家想象一下啊
它最基本的东西不就是一个波浪无数的波吗
我们说诶人能听见波的这个波
这个这个频率的范围不是有一个范围呢
从20HZ到那个5000HZ对吧
那伟大的香农先生
他就提出了一个香农采样定理
他就说对任何一个频率的信号
你只要采样的是那个密度是它频率的两倍
它就可以表示无损
所以实际上我们对声波的采样
只需要超过5K以上
比如说是他两倍或者四倍或者八倍就可以了
但实际上我的采样率会稍微高一点点
因为我刚才讲的就是说
我们实际上虽然我们能区分的声音不超过5K
但实际上很多的更高频的声音
对我们的音质是有影响的
所以呢我们会采样率会略高一点
但没关系
然后呢我们采样完之后呢
我们对采样的每个数据诶
我们进行它的就是量化处理
以及CORONIZEDCOTNIZE叫什么呢
叫做beat depth
那一般来讲一下
现代的这个就是音频的方法的话呢
我们有的时候会用比如说14个比特
有的人是用24个比特去存它的这个量
这里面有一个细节在里面
我没有展开啊
但实际上刚才我们讲的就是声音啊
它其实我们对它的感知
它的强度是一个非线性的
对不对
所以呢他这CORTATION呢也有很多流派
有的是用现行的方法
就是老老实实的就是123456789十
比如说我存到100万
我存这个变化
有的人呢codex的时候
我只是用那个对数
用对数的方法就是用指示的方法去传达
这样的话呢能够最大效率的利用我的存储空间
那各种方法其实大家都有各有利弊了
我们就不展开了
这里面有很多人做了僵硬的比较和分析
那么其实呢有了这些方法之后
我们就可以啊
把自然界的一切的声音
转化成一个在计算机里面存储的声音
这件事情其实真的不是在像大家想的那么
trigger的事情
就是在我刚刚接触电脑的时候
电脑其实是不能够放音乐的
那时候电脑只能发出那个我记得好像叫media音
还叫什么
就是好像是八位的那个音
那个音是很差很差的
早期的游戏就是用mini音去写出来的
就包括你们回想一下那个比如说像SUPERMARIA
像魂斗罗的音乐
都是用那种最简单的那个声音发出来的音乐
所以其实直到很后面
才有真正的电脑的音乐的播放器
那这里面就有很多的格式出来
比如像wave格式
像那个m p three是很后面的一个格式了
还有flag是那个就是无损的格式对吧
像OGG的格式
其实每种音乐格式啊
大家去看
我们在里面也是给大家做了一个简单的总结
其实有一些是无损的
比如像wave和flag就是无损的
那么有一些那些mp3
我们知道的和OGG它都是有损的
它就相当于说我是以以损失一定量的质量
但是呢我会极大的节约我的存储空间
这个对音乐存储其实意义非常的大
那么这里面的话呢给大家讲一个细节
就是说其实在游戏中的话
我们一般用的比较多的不是这个无损的格式
因为这个数据量太大
其实你的对游戏来讲的话
我们一般不会用无损的音乐格式
那么我们一般会用有损有损的话
大家会说为什么我们我们可不可以用mp3
其实mp3呢有两个问题
第一个问题呢
就是说它mp3这个格式设计的时候有个瑕疵
它只支持立体声
什么叫立体声呢
就是只有左右两个声道
而不能支持
比如说5.1音源的这个声音的这个采样
这个在游戏中的话呢
我们很多时候需要环绕音
那mp3就不能支持了
还有一点是什么呢
就是mp3呢是有非常重的专利保护
那就意味着说我要是支持mp3格式的话
我的引擎还要给他专利付费
大家想想诶
有点意思了
这有点像我们写芯片
写操作系统
我们突然遇到了专利墙
确实在游戏引擎里面有些数据格式
有些算法是有专利的
那所以呢在游戏引擎里面
大家还约定俗成吗
现在越来越多的人会选选用OGG这个格式
为什么呢
因为OGG这个格式它没有专利保护
所以谁都可以用
这个很有意思
就是你花了很多心思设计的一个格式
你申请了专利之后就没人肯用了
你不申请专利呢
反而用的人非常非常的多
这也是我们讲的开源的精神嘛
就像我们小引擎也是个开源引擎
也是一个道理好
所以呢其实每一种声音
就是每一种声音的格式的话呢
它都有各有利弊的
那么这个地方呢我希望同学们
当你在做引擎的时候
一定要区分清楚
就是说知道我们该用什么东西
那么其实你有了这个声音的基础原理
我们知道了声强
我们知道了声音的这个音色
我们知道了就是声音的存储的格式
并且把它整个数字化了
那其实是不是
我们就能做一个游戏引擎的声音系统了
其实这里面只是一个开始
因为游戏引擎最难最难的事
如何在一个三维的空间去注意啊
我们讲的一般讲的游戏
已经讲的都是三维游戏引擎
我去构建一个声音的场
让你感觉在这个世界里发生各种各样的事情
所以在三维空间如何去渲染声音
是一个很难的问题
注意啊
这里面这个词也用了一个渲染
确实它又是一套非常独立的一个渲染系统
这跟我们的这个就是光学的渲染是两个概念
但是其实它的复杂度
甚至他的专业度
我个人认为是超过了官
也不能说超过吧
至少他有足够深的东西
其实很多算法我也没有完全搞得特别清楚
但是我知道这些基本的概念
所以同学们如果将来有兴趣写自己的
这个声学引擎的话
我会建议大家很认真仔细的去理解
这些非常复杂的声学概念好
那首先的话呢就是在三维空间的话
我们实际上有无数的深远
每个声源呢它本身是很简单
就是一段声音的source对吧
举这个例子
比如说这是一段柴火在烧的粒子
但是呢这个柴火你在这个世界的不同位置
你听上去的感觉这就是不一样了
大家最简单的一个理解是不是越近的地方
它的火声越大对吧
越远的地方它的声音越小
对不对
但是呢诶它在你的左边
在你右边怎么区分呢
那我怎么知道我和这个声源之间的关系呢
所以呢这个时候在我做渲染的时候
就像我们在做这个光学渲染的时候
我们需要一个什么
需要一个camera对吧
我们需要一个观察者
他去对这个空间进行观察对吧
大家还记得在rendering的时候
我们说camera有什么属性哦
有他的position
有它的朝向
还有它的orientation对吧
然后我们算出一个view frustr矩阵
听上去是不是很简单诶
在深学的渲染中的话
我们首先要引入的一个东西是什么呢
叫做listener
这个listener呢其实一样的
它也有
即它有这么几个量
第一我要有我的位置
我在哪
一般来讲A跟我的角色上面身上对不对
如果你做个FPS游戏
没错
就在你的角色身上
但是呢如果你做一个TPS
第三人称设计游戏的时候
诶这个listener的位置还是蛮讲究的
你放到相机的时候会有点奇怪
你会觉得诶好像你人已经进入了什么地方
但是好像声音没有听到
你放到那个人身上也有点情况
因为你的视觉上又觉得我离他有点距离
一般来讲会放在啊你和他就是你的
你现在观察者的点和那个角色中间的某个点
那这个点就很玄学了对吧
就是很多游戏会自己调整
那么还有什么呢
就是速度
为什么这里面有点意思了
就是我们算那个
我们在做那个就是光学渲染的时候呢
相机的速度一般是不考虑
但其实也是考虑的
比如说我要做motion blur的时候
我是需要考虑的
对不对
当然在声学里面的话呢
我们也要考虑这个考虑
待会解释就是大名鼎鼎的多普勒现象对吧
我们需要考虑这个速度还有什么呢
就是我的朝向我
我的是这样的
我是侧过耳朵听还是正向他听
我听到的东西都是不一样的
所以listener对声学的渲染也是非常重要的
它是一个几何量好
那这个时候呢
我们就要基于它构建一个声音的空间感
那声音的空间感是怎么来的呢
其实这个问题啊
是有很多的专家很认真的去研究过的
这个其实非常有意思
就是啊当我们对世界的感知只有左耳和右耳
对不对
那我怎么去区分这个因缘离我的远近呢
那最简单的一个理解就是诶
声音他从左边和右边如果靠近我的左边一点
我左边听的音量会稍微大一点
因为右边隔着你的整个头部
它会稍微小一点
对不对
所以从声音的大小我能听出区别对吧
但其实呢我们人的感知能力是非常非常强的
我不仅仅是大小
还有什么呢
还有它到达我左右耳的时间的差距
我就能感知出它的这个就是比如说几行啊
应该是十几毫秒的差距
人就能感知出它的空间位置的关系的变化
这个是非常神奇的一件事情对吧
还有什么呢
还有就同样一个声音到达我左右左右的时候
它的音色会发生一点点的变化
而这种变化的话也会形成我对空间的感知
其实我这边跟大家讲一个有意思的概念
就是大家以以前我们在家里面构建音箱的时候
大家都喜欢说哎
我的家里构建一个5.1的环绕音箱
对不对
有的人更有钱一点
我做过气电影的音箱
我记得当时那个在博士
他这个博士是全球最著名的一个
就是当然了
他其实不是最专业的专业级
大家不用博士
但是的话呢就是我们大众去买的时候
都会觉得博士是最高端的
他做了一个研究
他说其实我只作为音箱
只有两个speaker
但是呢我可以让你产生一个真正的空间感
就是你会感受到一架直升飞机从你的前面飞过
你的头顶又飞到你头后面
大家会觉得很奇怪
那左右耳不是对称的吗
那我听不到声音的区别
为什么我能感觉到这样的变化呢
他的解释就是说
其实人的大脑和耳朵
经过就是百万年的进化之化
实际上我们的大脑很很敏锐的
能够通过这些刚上面讲的三个小小的变化
我就能够反向的就是那个绘制出来这个东西
大概是在什么空间位置
这也是我们亿万年进化的一种本能
所以我们以前讲叫听声
变那个变那个什么变武器来的方向
其实我个人相信啊
它还是有它的科学原理的
因为我们如果对听觉有足够的了解
你会发现这件事情你通过它的相位
通过他的那个就是音声音
同一个声音频率的微妙的变化
通过他之间的深深差的话
你确实就能得到这个空间感
而这个过程的话呢
我们叫做PN
那么penny的话呢
其实就是说当我的speaker有很多个channel
很多通道的时候
我通过调整在通道上的不同的声音的大小
甚至包括音色
包括它的latency
我能让你产生这种虚拟的空间的感觉
这个过程我们叫做penny这个算法
那么今天给大家讲的就是最简单的
比如说哎我怎么样让你感受到声音从左到右
比如说一个东西在移动
我怎么感觉到
那最简单的做法就是我线性的
比如说我把这边的音响从左边诶
移一点点移到右边去
那就是一个线性的这样的一个移动
对不对
但实际上这里有个很有意思的一个细节
就是人对声音的感知啊
其实是你的音强的这个平方
你感受到power
所以呢
这个时候就会出现一个数学上很有意思的事情
就是说当我这个声音源正在我的面前的时候
因为我的power都是用平方算的
你会发现你的声音就会小一半的感觉
这个事情非常神奇啊
我给大家听一个例子
这个例子就是从左到右移动声源
大家注意啊
这时候就此处应该戴上耳机会听得更清楚
你会发现中当那个声源移到你中间的时候
声音好像小了那么一点点
然后一会儿又恢复了
大家听一下
大家感觉到没有
就是中间有一段
你会觉得那个声音好像小了那么一点
实际上呢它的总音音响是没有变化的
但是他就是面power
他是那个音强的这个平方
所以呢你感受到的是那个东西
那好那就时候怎么办呢
哎我们一般用一个就是这个啊
最简单的算法
就是我保证你的平方永远是为1.0就可以了
这是我的一种归一化的方法
那怎么归一化呢
其实也比较简单
就是我用过最简单的sign cos n的函数就好了嘛
对吧
就是sin cos
我们讲一个是early in
一个是early那个easy in y easy out对吧
或者是那个那个这样一个方法
那在前面讲差池的时候
我们也讲过这个方法
然后大家听一下啊
对啊
这个时候听上去是不是发现诶
他的声音好像基本保持一致
其实中间还有一点点误差
其实这个呢是一个很很很简单的一个TRICKER
但是我们在做penny的时候
实际上我们是需要这样的一个技术的
但是这里面讲的是最简单的
从左耳到右耳了
那我们再讲更复杂的
比如说我们真的在一个空间上去表达一个方位
这个这个声音就比较复杂
就大家真的要用心去听
我们那个白色的点就代表音源的位置
然后你会发现音源的位置一直在变的时候
你虽然只有左右耳在听
但是你会感觉他的声音真的在变化
我的更左边一点哎
我的最右边
往中间来一点
然后到你的后面
到你的更后面
然后呢到你的前面
我不知道同学们的设备行不行啊
如果你们是用手机去看的话
我会建议大家插个小小的耳机
所以这其实是声音啊
audio designer很神奇的地方
但是这里面的就是说
当我的声源在我的不同位置
我的每一个左右声道的我要发生的变化的话
实际上是有大量的就是采集和测算组织出来
这样这样一个经验的变化
不是一个简单的数学运算
实际上呢这个东西呢是符合人体的心理学
认知的
这个实际上在很多的这个就是音频的公司的话
他们是做了大量的实验
那在我们计算机渲染中的话呢
我们只要把这些数据真的给他搬过来
就是说
比如说我可以对两边的这个音量进行调整
有的时候可能是调整它的位向移
有的时候我会调整它的
这个就是说他的那个就是那个
甚至我的频率进行一些调整
让你感受到诶我的是在空间形成一个定位感
这个其实比如说啊大家如果买那种高级音箱
比如5.1音箱的时候
你在家的时候就会有技师上门
帮你去校正和定位
他干的就是这个事儿
就是让你在这个对这个声音的空间感
是做的非常的准确
而不是只是简单的说啊
声音到了左边
声音到了右边
你要能听出前后左右上下的这种空间感
那这种就是一个定位的比较好的一个空间音箱
注意在这个时候
如果你们家的沙发或者什么位置变了的时候
你听的声音就已经有点不太一样了
当然我们打游戏的人也不需要这样
我的打游戏就是两个大耳机一戴我就可以了
所以的话呢一般来讲在游戏的生效中
我们目前主力的还是专注在就stereo display
就是说我两个耳朵的双耳的这种渲染的效果
达到最优嗯
所以这个东西的话呢是声音伸长的空间感
是由一个我的非常重要的一个
一个一个渲染的一个元素
这里面的话呢就是说啊有一些简单的公式
但是呢更多的是一些经验的公式
实现在我们的就是audio的引擎里面去好
那么声音呢还有一个很重要的属性
我们叫做attenuation
就是声音的衰弱
注意刚才你听到的声音是没有衰落的
只是在空间位置不同
那衰弱就我的最简单的理解
就是说越远声音越小
对不对
但实际上在游戏引擎里面
我们要实现的声音的attenuation系统啊
比这个要复杂得多
因为同样的音源
当你在距离你不同的位置的时候
它的高频和低频都会它的衰弱都会发生变化
这是为什么呢
因为就是说举个例子
比如说当你在你们你们啊如果看那个电影
或者说在真实的世界
你会发现啊
你有些高频的声音
你稍微远一点点
你其实就听不太清楚了
但是呢那种轰隆轰隆的那种低频的声音
你会听得非常的远
当然在我们的游戏的世界里面呢
有的时候我们为了表达一些效果
我们会在某一个区域把它的高频也会强化
然后呢在后面的话我会逐渐回到很低频的区域
就是叫base的一个区域
这里面的话我们就以吃鸡游戏为例
因为吃鸡游戏最重要的一点是什么
你听到了枪声
你要根据这个枪声的这个这个这个这个感觉
判断开枪的人离你的远近对吧
那这里面给大家讲一下这个东西是怎么做到的
你会发现就是哎当你跑到中等距离的时候
这时候高频的那种就是回响
混响会变得比较重对吧
然后呢哎当你跑得再远的时候
高频的混响逐渐的就消失掉了
这时候你听到的更多的是他那种低频的声音
这个呢实际上在我的audio engineer做的时候
或者或者sound designer做的时候
这三个音乐都会单独制作
让你之间进行插值
但是你听上去的感觉
就能够判断他的声音的远远近的变化
所以说如果我们去做一个O
就是游戏引擎里面的audio这个部分的时候
这个地方是一个非常重要的问题
但是现代游戏引擎
一般我的audio呢都是用中间件来解决的
所以中间件里面一般都会提供这样的一个
一个一个一个一个工具SDK给你
让你去做这个声音的这个ATTENSI
其实声音的ATTENTIATION对于游戏来讲非常重要
他很多时候给你构建这个世界的空间感
举个例子
比如说最简单的attention就是一个一个球形吧
就刚即使你刚才那样随着距离变化的话
实际上你往前后左右跑都是一样的
对不对
但是呢想象一下比较复杂的一个情况
就是诶我要做一个小溪
流水的小溪
那我不能大家想要流水的小溪
它是它的声音
每个地方都有对吧
每个地方都在流
但是你就想
你怎么可能在游戏中放无数个线性的声源呢
你只能放一个深渊
那怎么办
你第一种叫capsule
就是那种哎长圆柱胶囊的这样的一个
就是声音的衰减的shift
这样就你现在模拟什么东西呢
就是哎你你靠近小溪的时候
你大致感觉就是你离它越近
声音越大
离她越远
声音越小
但是呢你沿着小溪镜像去走的时候
这个声音不会特别的变化
这个其实在游戏中非常的常见
那更复杂的
比如说我定义一个空间域
比如说这个盒子状的区域
那我希望这个TENNATION的话呢
就是我想模拟这个声音是被墙阻隔阻隔住的话
那我的attention就是以这个盒子为单位
就是出了那个某一个范围
他就开始迅速的衰减
其实这就是我们应该没有办法在游戏世界里面
真实的进行生产的模拟
其实我们用这个attenuation呢
就给你制造了一种空间感
其实这件事情是非常的重要
包括它的混响也是受这个影响
那再讲一个
就是比如说我们在游戏里面要做一个高音喇叭
大家知道高音喇叭输出输出的生长
它实际上是有一定的定向性的
那实际上的话呢我们就要用这种qun shape的
这ATTINATION就能模拟这种诶
你走到喇叭面前
听着声音特别的吵
很刺耳
你稍微跑开一点点
诶
感觉声音帅还可以
勉强可以接受
其实这个东西都是用attenuation实现的
这也就是说attention的话呢
对于这个声音的这个场空间的构造
其实意义非常大
大家想想都很简单的东西对吧
但是当我们去在做一个真实的游戏引擎的时候
做一个真实的生效场的时候
就是如何在构建一个3D空间的时候
你发现这些东西都非常的重要
那接下来的话呢
比如说更复杂的就是环境
如果我们其实同样的声音被阻挡
有两种
一种是什么呢
就abstraction什么意思
就是说我有个障碍物
但障碍物你会发现声音啊
它是个波不
当它被阻挡的时候
他到那个被阻挡屋的那个
比如说边缘的那个地方
它就会产生新的这个波的扩散是什么
波的衍射对吧
大家想象一下我们小时候学的那个小孔
那个那个波的干涉的时候
你就会发现每个拐角的地方
又会形成一个新的波源
所以呢这个时候你听到那个声音和
假设这个波完全被阻挡了
就注意啊
比如说我隔了一面墙
其实我还是能听到墙那边的声音是什么呢
因为是声音推动这个强震动
然后这个墙又把这边的空气有震动了
所以我们也听到声音
那么其实在生长的这个系统里面的话
这两种东西的处理方法是完全不一样的
那么最简单的做法的话呢
就是说哎我们去做一些recasting
就是从声源设一些R
然后就散开来发散一下
就有点像那个我们在在前面讲渲染的时候
讲过一个
就是说诶我们用蒙特卡罗积分的方法对吧
我随机设一些瑞
然后呢我们去3sampling
我们去采样
当然这个方法非常废了
但是如果对于一些非常重要的声音
比如说啊我在打游戏中最重要的是什么
近处有颗手雷爆炸
那我们要因为其实这个事情比较简单
就是重要的event我是知道的
然后呢最重要的listener是谁
是你自己
所以event只有一个listener这一个
这个时候呢我在现代游戏中
我加一些RECOSTING的计算的话
也能够大致模拟这样的效果
所以这个其实对现代游戏引擎来讲
还是蛮重要的
因为比如说你玩一个射击游戏的话
你根据一个手雷爆炸声
它是传过来闷闷的
还是说诶听上去好像有点小
但是明显感觉是在拐角那边的时候
你能判断战斗是在哪发生
所以这件事情又非常的重要
所以这也是说声音啊
对于现在游戏的game play来讲是极为重要的
我的这句话的话
相信所有玩吃鸡游戏对吧
玩cs的游戏的玩家一定是非常赞同我的观点的
这个简直就是这两个游戏
你拿掉耳机之后
你基本上站立直接就没了
对不对
所以说其实这两种声音源的处理方法
也是现代游戏引擎非常重要的两个系统
那么接下来呢讲一个更复杂的概念
在这边我不展开了
就是混响
混响呢
其实是我们对游戏的空间感影响特别大的东西
大家想象一下
我们在那个游戏中经常有这样的场景
比如说你在一个教堂里面跟NPC对话对吧
比如说你骑着啊
比如说你骑着一匹马穿过一个桥洞对吧
你听到的马蹄声就会发生变化
这个就是混响
混响在我们的现实世界里面
是跟空间感跟材质感影响特别大的一个东西
那么混响呢
它一般来讲我们有333个东西构成
第一个叫干音
就是说你真实发出的声音没有经过任何反射
直接到你耳朵的
就directly到你的耳朵的声音
我们叫做干音
那么另外一个呢就是echo
就是诶你的是那个声音打到一面墙上
再反打到某个材质上
反射到你声音
叫做这个你的这个echo回音对吧
我们比如说对着一个大的这个水泥墙
一个空腔
我喊一嗓子
我可以听到自己的回音
唉
光有干音和回音够不够
其实不是的
你还有什么呢
还有他的尾音
就是那个声音啊
回音那个音除了静音的耳朵
其实很多声音是弹到另外一个面
然后来回弹弹弹弹弹弹弹弹
就会形成这样的一个几乎无限的循环
当然了
每一次都会有能量的衰减
它就会形成一个tale
那么这个回音和tell在我们的声音的系统里面
我们一般叫什么呢
叫做诗音
叫vet对吧
你说这个audio designer很有意思啊
他们用了一个dry and vet两个词就定义了
但是呢一个简简单单的dry and vet
其实就能定义出完全不一样的一个
空间的容积的感觉
那么在这里面的话呢
其实它有几个关键的量
第一个就是说诶你的声音是这个材料
是不是吸我的声波
大家会发现啊
就是不同的材质
对不同的声音的吸收是不一样的
还有一个什么呢
因为你空间的大小不同
他的这个声音来回的这个就是latency
这个延迟delay是不一样的
那么其实这里面呢有一个简单的表格
大家会发现一个很有意思的特点
就是说不同的材质啊
对不同波段的这个声音吸收率是不一样的
有的材质特别善于吸收高频的声音
有的材质特别吸收这个低频的声音
比如说我们最近在研究那个消音版吧
因为我们在在做一些办公室的这个
声音的处理的时候
我们就非常有意思的
就买的那种一个一小块板子上面
做了很多方方向的这种条件
包括我们在做一个专门的声音采集室
也是在解决这样的一个问题
其实所以最近我的升学的东西蛮感兴趣的
因为我们花了好多心血去做这个录音室
和专门的声音叫啊叫声音合成式
就是要保证他的升学达到一定的标准
所以我也被迫掌握了一点点的这个知识
所以确实你看到这个表格
你会发现哦
原来升学是很有意思
就是说它对它是一个材质和空间的一个
几何学的东西
然后呢最后能实现你想要的一个结果
那这里面有个细节
就是说我们听到的声音啊
如果完全没有回音
只有干音的话
那个声音听上去你会非常难受
我的人无论是说话还是放音乐
你是一定要听到一些reverb
就是一些混音的东西的
大家都有一个生活中的经验是什么
我们唱歌什么时候最好听
是不是在浴室时候唱歌最好听
我们很多同学都觉得自己在浴室里面都是麦霸
原因很简单
因为浴室里的混音效果是最好的
那么其实呢在我的这个就是说
各种各样的audio的引擎里面的话呢
其实对这个事情呢
他就用一个很简单的概念就定义清楚了
第一个就是诶我的高音的分量是多少啊
我这个我的写到最后了吧
其实第一个他他第二个呢
就是我的诗音的分量是多少
第三个是什么呢
哎我的声音来的时候
他的list就是pre delay
就是它的延迟是多少
它一般是以秒为单位
有的时候延迟可以达到0.5秒
那就表达是一个很空旷的这样的感觉
比如山谷里的感觉也可能是0.16秒
零点多少秒
那么还有一个是什么呢
叫half
Racial
half是什么呢
就是说因为我很难去精准的定义这个声音
对不同频率的声音的这种啊
reverb的这种这种强度大小的变化
对不对
它就统一的定义了一个量
这个量呢大概在0.5到十之间
他就说呢诶你在这个高频和低频中间
到底是你对高频的这个这个混音
这个效果更强一点
还是对低频的混音效果更强一点
那么就用这么一个简单的量
这四个量
artist就能做出你很多你想要的这个效果
所以这个混音的话实际上是现代这个audio engine
就是声音引擎非常重要的一个基础性的功能
那么另外一个的话呢
就刚才大家同学们可能也我的
我怀疑我的一讲声音的时候
同学们就会怀疑
就会猜到
我要讲的就是大名鼎鼎的多普勒效应式的
在游戏里面的话
多普勒效应也是一个非常重要的一个效果
因为你比如说你敢敢像这个场景里面
你感受一架飞机扑面而来的时候好吧
实际上他的飞机的声音是不变的
但就是因为跟你的距离和速度发生关系的时候
哎一直在变化对吧
这个是一个我的中式英语有讲过的
那多普勒的原理其实也是非常简单
就是说因为你在运运动介质中运动的时候
你一直会产生这个波
这个波就以那个点为圆心扩散
所以呢他最后当你感受到那个震动的频率
就会不一样
其实这个的话呢
实际上在啊其实不仅是在升学啊
甚至在光学中都是有用处的
比如说像那个啊
我记得好像那个我们讲我们中国的那个
就是那个高能粒子研究研究了
就超高速的那个宇宙射线打中大气层的时候
它会出现一个叫什么辐射
那个辐射就是因为它那个粒子的速度
那个那个大于它在那个介质中的光速
然后呢就会产生一些很有趣的辐射
其实跟这个原理是有点像的
所以说多普勒效果的话
是一个非常重要的一个效果
那么这也是我们在游戏中对速度的感知
特别重要的一个效果
比如说当你在高速移动
比如说我在开车的时候对吧
当我在空中进行追击作战的时候
甚至有有一颗子弹从我旁边送打过去的时候
其实在游戏引擎中
多普勒的效果是非常重要
因为它是一个打击感和速度感
很重要的一个来源好
那么其实讲了这么多声音啊
其实声音现在的发展和更复杂了
比如说我们现在如果渲染我的游戏引擎
渲染或者是采集
我们是来自于这个就是啊整个生产的采集
就是说因为我们现在假设所有的声音采集
都是有一个listener
就是左右耳
但是想象一下
我并不知道listener在哪里
我能不能采集一个整个声场呢
这个需求其实在以前是没有
但现在如果随着VR的需求越来越强的时候
其实我们需要对整个生产进行采集
这里面只是点一下
就是在VR的这个采集的时候
我们是对空间上进行声音的采样
就在这个案例里面
大家感觉到那个红色的点
就是我一直在变的这个空间
然后你会感觉到这个声音的小提琴的声音
一直在平衡
正在变化
所以说我们今天讲声音最重要的是一种临场感
其实我自己啊
家里还是有蛮不错的一个声音的设备
但是呢
就是我们比如说我们去听那个
交响乐的乐队的时候
我自己亲身的感受就是如果我在现场去听
和我在家里用我的音响设备去听的时候
你会感觉完全完全不一样
所以这也是我觉得声音这件事情的话啊
离做到我们想要的临场感
还是有很多很多的事情可以做的到
特别是大家去玩一些3A游戏的时候
我是特别推荐一个
就是说你在一个很安静的地方
找一个非常好的耳机
或者是一个非常好的一个环绕音箱
再去玩那个游戏
你会感觉他的感觉是完全不一样
这也是我一直认为一个高品质的游戏啊
他对声音的这个把握和表现一定要非常的到位
那么其实呢这边顺便给大家讲一句声音呢
现在其实虽然我们讲游戏引擎
声音是个非常重要的组成部分
但是呢一般来讲
很少有游戏引擎团队
会自己直接去写声音的引擎
一般我们会用中间键
那么这里面最大面积有两个
一个是f mod
一个是w wise对吧
那现在f mod呢好像维护的有一点拉胯
所以w vs越来越受大家重视
单身的最新的游戏游戏引擎
他们也会意识到
就是说可能还是需要自己直接去写声音
引擎对吧
比如说像ARREAL对吧
那么所以的话呢
其实声音的MIDWELL是一个非常重要的一个东西
那声声音的middle为什么这么重要呢
实际上他是让他给我们的audio designer
提供了一个非常符合他们的习惯的
一个调音环境
这样的话呢让我的audio engineer
我们在游戏引擎工程师里面的话
我只专注于如何在3D世界里面去进行
这些声音的组合渲染
而我们会把声音的生产或者是管理
全部交给了AUDESIGNER
其实渲染的有一部分
也是由这些meteor来完成的
那这里面的话呢给大家举个例子
就是这里面比如说我们拿我放一个视频
就这里面是一个简单的音效
诶
我的audio designer在这个mile world里面
它有这样的一个界面对吧
它可以加上一个效果器
然后呢可以给他加上
就是刚才讲的那个reverb
就是婚姻的时候诶
它可以给它加上各种各样的干湿音
效果和空间的效果
这就是我的audio designer每天在做的东西
当然了
我今天讲的所有的声音啊
还是实话实说
还是声音的基础
实际上你真的作为一个复杂的世界的话
那个声音其实非常的复杂
举个例子吧
比如说以那个最新的那个这一作
我们那个就是啊
就是PS5的一个猛推的一个游戏蜘蛛侠对吧
那大家会发现
就是他为了表现一个曼哈顿的这个音场的效果
大家想象一个城市里面的音乐
是不是非常的复杂对吧
其实当你在城市的每一个点
每个区域
他的混音效果都是不一样的
所以他为此专门做了一套算法
把整个曼哈顿的每个区域的
他的混音的这个效果都归因纳成了不同的类型
然后呢形成了这样一个不同颜色的分布图
然后这个时候才能实现
那个SPIDERMAN在曼哈顿穿来穿去的时候
你听到整个城市的感觉不一样
接下来有段视频
这段视频里面的话呢
他把这个蜘蛛侠的其他的音效全关了
比如他的脚步声啊
空气中的其他声音
就让你去听那个环境原因
大家感觉一下
这里面每一个蓝色的点就代表了一个姻缘
所以我们经常讲说大家想玩开放世界的游戏
其实开放世界的游戏引擎
技术的要求是非常高的
当然你要做的质量很高
如果做得非常简单
也是很容易的一件事情
所以讲到这一趴的话
我们今天的课程差不多所有的内容全部讲完了
差不多也快两个小时吧
一个小时40分钟
不过今天PPT准备的实在是内容量太大了
我们到最后一刻还在改
因为确实这2part的内容特别多
我们做了很多减法
所以忘了一件事
我忘了把那个就是我的那个reference的那些
就是供大家学习的参考资料补上去
我们争取在后面发的这个PDF上给大家补上去
那么再次感谢我的那个课程组的小伙伴
就是那个大家很辛苦准备了这期的课程
然后呢
今天我的课程的部分就到此了
那同学们有没有什么问题可以问我啊
这个同学问我的问题很有意思
他说他想写一个CPU上的粒子系统
是不是很适合用ECS系统去去去开发
其实呢这个首先大的方向是对的
确实是如果用最简单的这种编程模型的话呢
做了你的效率一定是非常低的
因为你的你的数据一块块层
然后的话呢你去访问他
你去处理它效率都很低
用ECS的思想就是把数据全部集中在一起
那这样处理起来是非常好
但是呢他不需要用的那么复杂的
什么这个什么NTT啊
这些概念了
它其实就是一个非常简单的
我认为是那个就是那个就是那个DOP的
开发概念
就是DORANGE的programming
就是面向数据的编程
就是你把所有party系统的数据全部集中在一起
然后呢一类particle
一个process把数据啪就处理完了
那个效率是很高
然后在中间的话呢你还可以用SMD
就是我们上次以前讲过
就是一条主直令
同时进行四条浮浮点数的vector运算的指令
那这样算起来速度就会很快
所以这个基本的架构的话呢
其实已经非常成熟了
但是呢这个实话实说
我们无论在这个CPU上优化了多好
它一定是比GPU上是要慢的
但是呢就是说实际上这两个东西呢
都是有存在的价值
因为GPU上实现的particle
虽然现在computer是非常的强大
但是呢他还是有很多的决心局限
就有些比较复杂行为的particle没办法做
而这一点呢就是我的CPU的这个优势
所以的话呢CPU上的一个高性能的particle
系统的实现
对于现代游戏引擎来讲还是有实战价值的
哇这个问题问得好
专业同学问我说
粒子系统可以和我们前面讲的动画系统
和物理系统相结合吗
啊实话实说
这是yes的
特别是对于现代的这个粒子系统来讲的话
虽然最早期的粒子系统
就是你看到一些小东西飞来飞去对吧
但是你看我们在这节课中讲的
那些比较复杂的那些粒子系统的话
首先比如说它有大量的环境的互动
那么这个时候其实我们会用到物理系统
甚至有些最前沿的粒子系统的话
都加入了一些物理的解算
它能够保证这些东西能够
符合一定的物理学规律
它比如说我们能表现一个悬挂着的这种这个
教练对吧
或者是很多小球之间彼此之间进行刚性结算
不会不会就是穿插到一起去
那么的话呢就是动画就更重要了
就比如像我们这次讲的crowd的话
实际上你可以认为它就在粒子系统里面
实现了一个非常轻量的一个动画系统对吧
这是我们把一个轻量的动画系统
in banded into我的一个粒子系统
但其实反过来讲讲哈
就是粒子系统也可以直接从动画系统中间
形成这样的一个融合
比如说我们在很多很复杂的效果
比如说一个角色诶走着走着
他突然变成了很多的沙尘这样效果
那这个里面就是有些有这样一个融合的需求
其实啊现代粒子系统
有的时候它其实和我们的影视特效系统
是深度结合在一起的
比如举个例子吧
比如说像胡迪尼对吧
他是我们现在看到很多很酷的这种影视特效的
这个工具
那么它的效果
它的它的很多表现
越来越多的集成到我们现代的游戏引擎里面了
甚至数据之间是实现了互通
第三个问题是同学问
我说刚才那个crowd的粒子系统的话
你们的SDF就是空间的
就是有正负向的
这个距离场的话是预预先送
算好了吗
啊这个在早期的引擎中呢
还真的是运气算好的
比如说我给你一个巨大的城市对吧
那我肯定我就有它的设计图
这个城市也不会变
那我肯定可以算好
包括我上过的那个direction field
但是其实呢在现代游戏引擎里面
特别是我们有了越来越多的这种
比如说global in an ination
就是全局光照的这样的一些计算
因为其实很多全局光照算法
他上来就需要你对这个空间算这个SDF
所以呢其实这个SDF的话呢
在游戏引擎里面
我们认为是可以real time直接算出来
但是它的精度可能没有那么高对吧
包括我们可能是要把它算的view dependent的一点
就是说哎跟着离我的眼睛看得近的地方
我的这个密精度高一点
远的地方我的微低一点
但现在在现在这个现代的GPU上的话呢
算一个场景的SDF的话已经不是特别难了
我们可以实时去算它
所以SDF有的时候会成为很多计算机的
我认为是标配
比如说我算好一个场景的SDF
我可以用它来去扰动particle对吧
我的particle在空中乱飞的时候
我让他不要穿到我的物体里面去
那么特别是有些GPU追问的particle的话
用SDF算出来的效果就真的是非常的好
你能感觉他好像沿着那个物体的表面在流动
这个是一个我们认为非常重要的效果
但同时的话呢我也可以用它来做我的GI
我的全局光照
哇这个问题有点难
同学问我说游戏中的音效数据是怎么组织的
其实呢游戏中的音效数据的组织还是蛮复杂的
那么比如说以一个实战的引擎为例
一般我们会接入一个以那个audio midware中间件
比如说我们接入f mode或者接入w wise
其实在音乐家在那个audio designer事件里面
他只是放入了很多的声音的clips
就是说诶就像动画我放入很多原始的数据
然后呢在游戏引擎里面
我们会触发各种各样的event
然后各种各样的事件的时候
就会触发各种各样声音的混合的需求
然后当这些混合器
它就会从这些clips里面选出这些声音
根据我们刚才讲的混音的方法呀
或者播放的规则
他们进行这个生成各种各样的音乐
但在游戏中的话呢
我们会进行8G的控制
比如同一时刻
我最多播放的音源的数量不能超过多少个对吧
这个这个就非常简单
这就是我的声音资源的国际最基础的管理
你可以认为就是我假设一个游戏
我用了1000个声源
那我1000个声源就会在启动的时候
加载到我的内存中
或者加载我的硬盘
在我的硬盘上
然后我用的时候我就调用它
但实际上的话呢
在现在的一些声音的这个中间件
包括我的引擎中都会提供这种different loading
什么意思
就是说很多的特别是音乐
特别是有一些效果
我们确定用不到的时候
我们就不去加载它
否则的话你会发现游戏
光光把它的音乐和音效加载进来的话
哎你就吃掉了几百兆甚至是上戏的内存
但我们游戏中内存是最就是最稀缺的一个资源
所以现在的音效和音乐的资源的管理的话呢
更像是我的场景啊
网格啊
动画的管理啊
就是用到了我去调用它
这里面就会有一套比较复杂的
就是调用的规则体系
但是呢它基础的思想就是
比如说我以关卡为单位
我把这个关卡所有用到的音效和声音
我有一个表格
那我就把这个相应的东西漏进来
我切换关卡的时候呢
哎我重用的部分我保留下来
我不需要的地方把它移除掉
我再去加载
就是新需要这个就是两边的difference
我把它下载进来
所以这个呢也是就是现代的游戏引擎
音效的一个啊音效资源的一个管理方法
好的
那我今天的话差不多也是一小时50分钟
那今天要不先这样好的
谢谢大家
那我们争取在下周下周我们再见面
OK好
谢谢大家